there is a famous story about Einstein
that he used to you know go think think
and then go for a walk and like he would
whistle and sometimes so I remember the
first time I heard this story
I thought how interesting so the
coincidence that he came to him when he
was whistling but in fact it's not this
is how it works in some sense that
you have to prepare for it but then the
moment it happens when you stop thinking
actually it's okay the moment of
Discovery is the moment when thinking
stops and you know you kind of you kind
of almost become that truth that you're
seeking
the following is a conversation with
Edward Frankel one of the greatest
living mathematicians doing research on
the interface of mathematics and quantum
physics with an emphasis on the
langlands program which he describes as
a grand unified theory of mathematics he
also is the author of love and math the
heart of hidden reality
this is the Lex Friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Edward Franco
you open your book love and math with a
question
how does one become a mathematician
there are many ways that this can happen
let me tell you how it happened to me so
how did it happen to you so first of all
I grew up in the Soviet Union
in a small town near Moscow
called columna
and I was a smart kid you know in school
but mathematics was probably my least
favorite subject
not because I couldn't do it I was you
know a straight A student and I could do
all the problems easily but I thought it
was incredibly boring
and
um since the only math I knew was what
was presented at school
I thought that was it and I was like
what kind of boring subject is this so
what I really liked was physics
and especially quantum physics so I was
buying
uh I would go to a bookstore and buy
popular books about elementary particles
and atoms and things like that and read
them you know devour them
and so I thought my dream was to become
a theoretical physicist
and to delve into this finer structure
of the universe you know so then
something happened when I was 15 years
old uh it turns out that a friend of my
parents
was a mathematician who was a professor
at the local College it was a small
College preparing Educators and teachers
it's a provincial Town imagine it's like
a 117 kilometers from Moscow which would
be something like 70 miles I guess you
do the math I like how you remember the
number exactly yeah it's not funny how
we remember numbers yeah so his name was
evgeny evgenievich Petrov yeah and if
this doesn't remind you of the great
works of Russian literature then you
haven't read them
like War and Peace you know like with
the patronym nickname yeah but this was
all real this was all happening so my
mom One Day by chance met is ganovic and
told him about me
but that was this bright kid and
interested in physics
and he said oh I want to meet him I'm
going to convert him into math
and my mom's like nah my ass he doesn't
like mathematics so they said okay let's
let's see what they can do
so I went to see him so I'm about 15.
and a bit a bit uh arrogant I would say
you know like average teenager
so he says to me
so I hear that you are
um interested in in physics Elementary
particles I said yeah sure
for example do you know what quirks
and I said yes of course I know what
quarks quarks are the you know
constituents
of particles like protons and neutrons
and it was one of the greatest
discoveries in theoretical physics in
the 60s that those particles were not
Elementary but in fact had the smaller
parts
and he said oh so then you probably know
representation theory of the group su3
this is like as you worked so
in fact
I wanted to know what was what were the
underpinnings of those theories I knew
the story I knew the narrative a new
kind of this basic story of what this
particles looked like but how did
physicists come up with these ideas
how were they able to theorize them
and so I remembered you know like it was
yesterday so he pulls out a book
and it's kind of like it's like a Bible
you know like a like a substantial book
and he opens um somewhere in the middle
and there I see the diagrams that I saw
in popular books but in popular books
there was no explanation and now I see
all these weird symbols and equations
it's clear that it is explained in there
oh my God
he said you think what they teach you at
school is mathematics
it's like no this is real mathematics
so I was instantly converted
that you understand the underpinnings of
physical reality
you have to understand what su3 is you
have to learn what are groups what this
group su3 what are representations of
sc3 there was a coherent
and beautiful I could appreciate the
beauty even though I could not
understand
heads and tails of it but you were drawn
to the the methodology the
the the Machinery of all such
understanding could be attained well in
retrospect I think what I was really
craving was a deeper understanding
and up to that point the deepest that I
could see was for those diagrams but for
that story that you know a proton
consists of three quarks and the neutron
consists of trick works and they're
called up and down and so on
but I didn't know
that there was actually underneath
beneath the surface there was this
mathematical theory if you can just link
around it what Drew you to quantum
mechanics
is there some romantic notion of
understanding the universe well what is
interesting to you is it the puzzle of
it or is it like the philosophical thing
now I am looking back yeah so um
whatever I say about Edward at 15 yeah
he's colored by
uh my you know all my experiences that
happen in in the meantime I should say
current views and so on for the people
who may not know you I think your book
and your presentations kind of revealed
that that 15 year old is still in there
somewhere
I think it is a conflict some of the joy
he's probably still here now yes yeah in
some way
yeah I think it was a joy of Discovery
and the joy of going deeper into the
kind of the
uh to the root uh to the so the deepest
structures of the universe the secrets
the the secrets and we may not discover
all of them we may not be able to
understand but we're going to try and go
as far and as deep as we can I think
that's what was the motivating factor in
this
yeah there's this mystery there's this
dark room and there's a few of these
mathematical physicists they're able to
shine
a flashlight briefly into there
uh we'll we'll talk about it but it also
kind of makes me sad that there's so few
of your kind that have the the
flashlight to look into the room
it's interesting
um I don't think there are so few to be
honest because I think I find a lot of
people are actually interested if you do
talk if you talk to people you know like
some people you wouldn't expect to uh to
be interested in this uh from all walks
of life from people of
all kinds of professions I tell them I'm
a mathematician and the mathematician
okay so that's a separate story a lot of
people I think have been traumatized by
their experience in their math classes
we can talk about it later but then they
ask me what kind of research I do and
I I mentioned that I I work on the
interface of math and quantum physics
and their eyes light up and say oh
quantum physics or like Einstein's
relativity I'm really curious about it I
watched this podcast or I watch that
podcast you know and I've learned this
it's like what do you think about that
so I actually find that that actually
physicists are doing great job at
educating
the public so to speak and uh in terms
of
um
popular books and videos and so on
mathematicians are behind that we're
starting to catch up a little bit have
been starting last 10 years but when
we're still behind but I think people
are people are curious
science is a is still a very much uh you
know something that people want to learn
because that's our kind of uh the best
way we know to establish some sort of
objective reality whatever that might be
yeah to figure out this whole puzzle to
figure out the secrets that the Universe
holds things that we can agree on kind
of you know like even though for me at
this point I always you know make an
argument that our physical theorists
always change they get updated so you
had Newton's theory of gravity
then um Einstein's theory you know
superseded it
but in mathematics
it seems that theories don't change
Pythagoras Theorem
has been the same for the last 2500
years x squared plus y squared equals z
squared we don't expect that next year
suddenly it will be z cubed you know so
and so that to me is actually even more
um hints even more at home how how much
we are connected to each other because
dagger's theory if you think about it or
any other mathematical theorem
means the same thing to anyone in the
world today regardless of their cultural
you know bringing uh religion you know
ideas ideal ideology gender whatever
nationality race whatever right and it
has meant the same to everyone
everywhere and most likely will mean the
same
so that's to me kind of an antidote
to the kind of
divisiveness that we sometimes observe
these days where it seems that we can't
agree on anything
to the political complexity of uh two
plus two equals five and George Orwell's
1984. I was in the Soviet Union in 1984
and so in many ways I see that it was
President the novel was present but we
still have not found the dictator who
would actually say two plus two equals
five and would demand their citizens to
repeat that the Knight is still young
has not happened yet
but it does feel like math and physics
are both sneaking up to a deep truth
from slightly different angles and you
stand at the crossroads or at the
intersection of the two it's interesting
to ask what do you think is the
difference between physics and
Mathematics in the way physics and
Mathematics look at the world
there is actually an essential
difference
which is that physicists are interested
in describing this universe
okay mathematicians are interested
describing all possible mathematical
universes of which uh you know and some
of our work I still consider myself more
of a mathematician than a physicist My
First Love for physics notwithstanding
um mathematicians are in a way
we have more diversity if you if you you
might say so we we are accepting for
instance uh our universe uh has three
special spatial dimensions and one time
Dimension right so what I mean is that
allegedly allegedly observed but that
way I can observe today right so of
course there are theories where there
are some hidden Dimensions as well well
let's just say absorb to observe
dimensions
um so this tabletop has two Dimensions
because you can have two axes two
coordinate axes now X and Y but then
there is also a third one to describe
the space of this room
and then there's a Time Time Dimension
so realistic theories of physics have to
be
about
spaces of of three three dimensions or
space time so four dimensions but
mathematically we are just as interested
in theories in 10 space time Dimensions
or 11 or 25 or whatever or or infinite
dimensional spaces you know
so that's the difference
on the other hand I have to give it to
the physicists we don't have the same
satisfaction that they have of having
their theories
um confirmed by an experiment we don't
get to play with big machines like LHC
in Geneva A Large Hadron Collider that
recently discovered you know the Higgs
boson and some other things
for us it's all like a mental exercise
in some sense we do we prove things by
using rules of logic and that's our way
of confirming experimental confirmation
if you will but I think we kind of I
kind of Envy a little bit my friends
visits that they they get to they get to
experience this sort of these big toys
you know and play with them but it does
seem that sometimes as you've spoken
about abstract mathematical Concepts map
to reality and it seems to happen quite
a bit that's right so the mathematics is
the underpins physics obviously it's a
language the the book of nature
famously said it's written in the
language of mathematics and the and the
you know the the letters in it are the
circles triangles and squares and those
who don't know the language I'm
paraphrasing
are left to wander in the dark Labyrinth
that's a famous quote from Galileo which
is very true and has become even more
true more recently in the in theoretical
physics in the more in the most
um actor of
far out
parts of the theoretical physics that
have to do with Elementary particles and
and as well as the the structure of the
cosmos at the large scale what do you
think of uh Max tag Mark or wrote the
book mathematical universe
so do you think just lingering on that
point you think at the end of the day
the future Generations will all be
mathematicians
meaning meaning the ones that deeply
understand the way the universe works at
the core is it just
mathematics
at the core of you know
I would say mathematics is one half of
the core so the book is called love and
math yeah okay so these are the two
pillars
yeah in my view yes in other words you
can't cover everything by math so
mathematics gives you tools it gives you
way up uh
kind of a clear
vision
but mathematics by itself is not enough
for one to have a harmonious and uh and
balanced life you know so I I am
suspicious of any theory that
declares that everything is mathematics
so math can generate things that are
beautiful but it can't explain why it's
beautiful Matthew could say is a way to
discern patterns to find regularities in
the universe and both physical and
mental Universe the mathematics explores
the mind as much as it explores
um the physical world around us and it
helps us to find those patterns
um which kind of which makes our
perception more sophisticated our
ability to perceive things such as
Beauty
you know and
it sharpens our ability to see to see
beauty to understand Beauty so a world
becomes more complex
from thinking that our
that our that Earth is flat we go to
realizing that it is round that is shape
as a sphere
so that we can actually travel around
the Earth you know so there isn't a
place where we hit the end so to speak
and then
um
proceeding in the same vein then
Einstein's general relativity Theory
tells us that
our space-time is not flat either
this is much harder to to imagine the
band a band three-dimensional or
four-dimensional three-dimensional space
or four-dimensional space time because
this idea that the space around us is
flat is so deeply entrenched and yet we
know from this from this Theory
and from the experiments that have
confirmed it
that
a array of light bends around a star as
if being attracted by the by the force
of gravity but in fact the force of
gravity is the bending it's just that
it's not only depending on the space
it's also the bending of space-time
there is a curvature
not only between special spatial
dimensions
the way parallels and meridians come
together in a small scale they look like
perpendicular lines but if you zoom out
you see that the spacer at a curving the
space they are sort of the the tracks
along which the space gets curved that's
that's the that would be the curvature
of spatial Dimensions but in fact now
throw in time and one time imagine a
sphere which lives which has one of the
meridians correspond to time and the
perilous crisp into space I can't
imagine it but you can I can write
mathematical formula expressing that
curvature and that's in fact that
curvature is responsible for the force
of gravity attraction between the sort
of simplest instantiation of it
attraction between two planets all
between two human beings
at the time
bending time
it's not very nice that what that theory
did to time because
it feels like the marching of time
forward is fundamental to our Human
Experience
there of time
marching forward nicely
seems to be the only way we can
understand the universe and the fact
that you can start now up to now there
are people who claim that they can that
they have they possess other ways of of
experiencing it so truly can visualize
messing with time
well messing with time but not
necessarily messing with time because
one point of view is that you know
I think who who was it I think William
Blake
who wrote that eternity loves time
production
so
one point of view is that it is eternity
which is fundamental where time stands
still which our mind conceptualizes as
the time
so but in fact you know it's not
something mystical if you think about
when you about it
when you really absorbed in something
time does stand still and then you look
at the clock and it's like oh my God two
hours have passed and it felt like a
couple of seconds
when you are absorbed when you're in
love when you are passionate about
something when you're creating something
you're we lose ourselves and we lose the
sense of time and space for that matter
you see so there is only that which is
happening that creative process
um so I think that this this is familiar
to all of us and we may be actually the
closest to the truth at that moment
so yes so then there is a point of view
that this is where we are we are who we
are at our sort of fundamental at our
fundamental level and after that the
Mind comes in
and tries to conceptualize it it's like
oh because I was writing something
um
I was writing a book I was painting this
painting or maybe I was watching this
painting and got totally absorbed in it
or I fell in love with this person
that's what happened but in the moment
when it's happening you're not thinking
about it you're just there yeah we
construct narratives around the set of
memories that that seem to have happened
in sequence or at least that's the way
we tell ourselves that and we also have
a bunch of weird human things like
Consciousness and the experience of free
will that we chose a set of actions as
the time unrolled forward right
and we are intelligent conscious agents
making taste taking those actions
but what if all of that is just an
illusion an illusion and a nice
narrative would tell ourselves sure
that's a really difficult thing and
imagine imagine that to make it really
Catch-22 that I'll imagine that our
minds and are set up in such a way yeah
that they can't approach the world or
experience otherwise
so in other words to understand to see
that from a more
kind of all-encompassing point of view
we have to step out of the Mind
well I wonder what's the more honest way
to look at things
but I think we like to be to play with
time I think we like to play with these
experiences with all the drama of it
with all the memories with all the
tribulations I think we love it we love
it otherwise we wouldn't be doing it I
think this or Earth loves it The
evolutionary process somehow loves it
whatever whatever this thing that's
being created here on Earth it seems to
like to create like to allow its
children to play with certain uh yeah
truths that they hold this subjective
truths that are useful for the
competition or whatever this dance that
we call Life broadly Define not just
humans and and you know I'm glad you
mentioned that because
what I find fascinating is that the
greatest scientists are on record
saying that when they were making their
discoveries they felt like children so
Isaac Newton said to myself I only
appeared as a child playing on the
seashore and every once in a while
finding a prettier Pebble or a prettier
shell whilst I think some he says
something like the infinite ocean of
knowledge lady was lying before me
who probably it was the greatest
mathematician of the second half of the
20th century the French mathematician
Alexander grotonic
wrote that discover is a privilege of a
child
the child who is not afraid to be wrong
once again to build to look like an
idiot you know to to try this and that
and paraphrasing and go through trial
and error that is for them in other
words for them
that innocence
of a child who is not afraid
who has not yet been told that it cannot
be done okay
that was essential to Scientific pursuit
to scientific discovery
and now and now also compared to Pablo
Picasso a great artist right so who said
every every child is an artist the
question is to how to preserve that as
we grow up
do you struggle with that you're one of
the most respected
mathematicians in the world
uh your Berkeley you're like this this
is the stature you're supposed to be
very like you know yeah sometimes I joke
I say I I think I take an elevator to
the top of the Eiffel Tower every day
yeah and you're supposed to speak like
royalty uh do you struggle to let those
uh strip all of that away to ReDiscover
the child when you're thinking about
problems when you're teaching when
you're thinking about the world
absolutely I mean that's part of being
human because when we grow up I mean all
of them all of these great scientists I
think they were so great in part because
they were able to maintain that
connection okay in that Fascination that
vulnerability
um that spontaneity you know and uh
um kind of looking at the World Through
The Eyes of a child but it's difficult
because you know you go through
education system and for many of us
uh it's not especially
helpful for maintaining that connection
that we kind of like we are being told
certain things that we accept
take for granted and so on and little by
little and also we get hit every time we
act different okay every time we act
that that's in a way that doesn't fit
sort of the pattern we get punished by
the teachers get punished by
parents and so on and don't get respect
when you act childlike in your thinking
when you are fearless and
uh looking like an idiot that's right
because there's a hierarchy nobody wants
to look like an idiot you know once you
start growing up or you think you're
growing up yeah in the beginning you
don't even think of you don't think in
these terms you just play you're just
playing and you are open to
possibilities to these infinite
possibilities that this world presents
to us so how do we I'm not saying that
education system should not be also uh
kind of taming that a little bit
obviously
the goal is balance
that acquiring knowledge
so that
we can be more mature and more
discerning more discriminating in terms
of our approach to the world in terms of
our connections to the world and people
and so on but how we do we do that while
also preserving that innocence of a
child
and my guess is that there is no formula
for this it is
alive is an answer every life every
human being is one particular answer to
how do we find balance
uh that's once imperfect approximation
approximate solution
but we could look we can look up to the
great ones yeah who have
credentials in the sense that they have
shown and they have proved that they
have done something that other humans
appreciate our civilization appreciates
say Isaac Newton or Alexander grotonic
or Pablo Picasso so they have
established their rights to speak about
this matters and we could not dismiss
them as mere Madman
they say okay well if the same thing was
said by somebody who never achieved
anything in in that in their in their
field of endeavor you will be it would
be easy for us to dismiss it but when it
comes from someone like Isaac Newton
we take notice so I think it's something
important that they teach us and
especially today in this age of AI
of course there's a big elephant in the
room always which is called AI yeah
right and so I know that you are an
expert in this subject
and we are going we're living now in
this very interesting times of new AI
systems coming online pretty much every
couple of weeks
so
I kind of um to me that whole debate
about
what is it what is artificial
intelligence where is it going what
should we do about it
needs an influx of this type of
considerations that we've just been
talking about
that for instance the idea that
inspiration creativity doesn't come from
accumulation of knowledge because
obviously child a child has not yet
accumulated knowledge and yet the great
ones are on record saying that a child
has a capacity
to to create
and at an adult
credits the inner child the inner child
yeah for this capacity to create as an
adult you see that's kind of weird if we
take the point of view
that everything is computation
everything is accumulation of knowledge
that just bigger and bigger data sets
finer and finer neural networks and then
we will be able to replicate human
consciousness if we take that point of
view then what I just said kind of
doesn't fit because obviously a child
has not been fed any training data as
far as we know yet they're perfectly
capable of of you know or distinguishing
between cats and dogs for instance and
stuff like that but much more than that
they're also capable of that
you know wide-eyed in the sort of
perspective
so does can it really be captured that
perspective that sense of or can it
really be captured by computation alone
I actually I don't know the answer so
I'm not sort of trying to
uh to present a particular point of view
interesting to question
um any theory that starts out by saying
life is this or Consciousness is this
because when you look more closely you
recognize that there are some other
things at play
which do not quite fit the narrative
and it's hard to know where they come
from it's it's also possible that the
evolutionary process has created
is the very it is computation and the
and the child is actually not a blank
slate but the result of one of the most
incredible
several billion year old computations uh
that
that had explored all kinds of aspects
of of life on Earth
of of war and love and Terror and
ambition and violence and invention all
of that from the bacteria to today so
like that young child is not is not a
blank slate they call me they're they're
actually they hold within them the
knowledge of several billions of years
right the question is whether as a child
you carry that in the form of the kind
of computational algorithms that we are
aware today you see what what strikes me
as unlikely
is that
how should I put it how interesting that
you know we you you are a computer
scientist and there are other people
come I have studied computer science so
I know a little bit
and so it's tempting to say
oh
the whole world
is computer science or is based can be
explained by computer science yes why
because it makes me feel good because I
have mastered it I have learned it my
ego is very happy and people come to me
and and they look up to me and they
Revere me kind of like priests in the
old in old days when the religion was
Paramount wonder when you would be would
tend to explain things in theological
religious terms today science has
progressed there are fewer people who
kind of buy into religion official
religion you know so
we have this urge I suppose to to
explain and to know and to dissect and
to analyze and to conceptualize which is
a wonderful quality that we have and we
should definitely pursue that but I find
it a little bit
unlikely
that the universe is just exactly what I
have learned
and not something that I don't know you
see
well there's a lot of interesting
aspects of the current large language
models
that one perspective of it I think
speaks to the love and math that you
talk to which is
they're trained on
the human data from the internet
so at its best a large language model
like gpt4
captures the magic of The Human
Condition on its full display it's full
complexity
it's just mimicking it's trying to
compress all the weirdness of humans
of all the debates and discussions the
perspectives all the different ways that
people approach solving different
problems all of that compressed so we
live we're each individual ants we only
have like we have a family we interact
with a few little ants and here comes AI
That's able to summarize like a tldr
report of humanity and that's the beauty
of it so I embrace it but I wonder I'm
very impressed by it I wonder if
they can be very impressive meaning
way more impressive in being able to
fake or simulate or emulate a human
right I'm glad you mentioned that
because that's just it seems to be the
Mantra it's just fake fake it till you
make it yeah isn't it isn't that what we
all do though no well yes we do that but
we also do other things we can be truly
in love we can be truly inspired when it
is not fake I do believe call me a
romantic okay but I do believe
and this is a very good I'm glad you're
putting it in these terms because I've
had conversations like that that yeah
fake it till you make it but that's like
that's what humans do yes we do that but
not all the time so and that is
debatable because also I speak from my
own experience and that's where the
first person perspective comes in the
subjective view I cannot prove to you
for instance or anyone else that there
are certain moments in my life where I
am genuine I am pure so to speak when
it's not faking it but I do I do have a
tremendous
a certainty of it and that's a
subjective certainty now I am as a
scientist I'm also trained to give more
um credibility to objective arguments
that another things that can be
reproduced things that I can demonstrate
that I can show
but as I get older there we go as I get
more mature hopefully you know
I'm starting to question why I am not
giving as much
credibility to my subjective
understanding of the world the kind of
the first person perspective when I
actually modern science has already sold
on that you know quantum mechanics
has shown unambiguously that the
Observer is always involved in the
observation
likewise yodel's incompleteness
ethereums to me
a show that how essential
is the Observer of the mathematical
theory for one thing that's the one who
chooses the axioms and we can talk about
this in more detail likewise Einstein's
relativity where
time is relative to The Observer for
instance that's brilliant you're just
describing all of these different scales
The Observer what they Observer science
so we signs of 19th century had the
from Modern perspective and I don't want
to offend anybody I had the delusion
that somehow you could analyze the world
being completely detached from it we now
know after the The Landmark achievements
of the first half of the 20th century
that this is nonsense that is simply not
true and this has been experimentally
proved time and time again so to me
I'm thinking maybe it's a hint that I
should take my first person perspective
seriously as well and not just rely on
kind of objective phenomena things that
can be proved in a in a in a traditional
sort of objective Way by setting up an
experiment that can be repeated many
times maybe I fall in love in a party
you know the deepest love my of my life
Perhaps Perhaps hasn't happened yet
Perhaps I will fall in love and this but
it's Unique it's a unique event you
can't reproduce it necessarily you see
so so in that sense you see how these
things are closely connected I think
that if you if we are declaring from the
outset that all there is to life is
you know computation in the form of
neural networks or something like this
however sophisticated they might be
I think we are from the outside denying
to ourselves the possibility that yes
there is the side of me which is not
faking it yes there is a side of me
which cannot be captured by Logic and
reason and you know what another great
scientist said bless Pascal
he said the heart has its reasons of
which the reason knows nothing
and then he also said the last step of
reason is to grasp that there are
infinitely many things Beyond Reason
how interesting this was not a
theologian this was not a priest this
was not a spiritual Guru
um it was a hardcore scientist who
actually developed I think one of the
very first calculators
how interesting that this guy also was
able to
uh impart on us that wisdom now you can
always say that's not the case
but why should we
from the outset
exclude this possibility that there is
something to what
he was saying that is my question I'm
not taking sides
um what I'm trying to do is to shake a
little bit the debate because most
mathematicians that I know and computer
scientists even more so they're kind of
already sold on this
um we are just you know reminds me of
this famous Lord kelvin's quote from the
end of 19th century
there's some debate whether he actually
said that but
never let a good story you know
he said physics is basically finished
yeah All That Remains is more more
precise measurement so I find a lot of
my colleagues are happy to say
yeah everything's finished we already
got we got it we got it uh maybe little
tweaks
in uh in the in our large language
models you know so now here's my
question
I'm kind of Playing devil's advocate a
little bit because I don't see the other
side
represented that much
and I'm saying okay could it be also
that if you believe in that that becomes
your reality
that you can kind of put yourself in a
box
where everything is competition and then
you start seeing things as as being such
it's confirmation bias if you will you
know this also reminds me you know I
think a good analogy is it's a friend of
mine uh Philip caution told me that in
France there is this literary movement
which is called ulipo
o u l uh IPO
and it's a bunch of writers and
mathematicians who create works of
literature
where in which they basically impose
certain constraints
a good example of this
is a novel which is called the void or
disappearance by a writer named George
pereck
which is a 300 page novel in French
with no no which never uses the letter e
which is the most used widely used
letter of the French language so in
other words he said these parameters for
himself I'm going to write a book where
I don't use this letter which is a great
you know it's a great experiment and I
upload it
but that's what it's one thing to do
that and to kind of show his
gamesmanship if you will and and his
proclivity and his ability as a writer
but it's another thing if at the end of
writing this book when you finish the
book he would say letter e actually
doesn't exist
and try to convince us that in fact
French French language does not have
that letter simply because he was able
to go so far without using it you see so
self-imposed limitation that's how I see
it and I wonder why
we should do that do we really need do
we really feel the urge to say the world
is like that the world can be explained
this way or that way and I'm saying it
you know it's a personal question for me
because I am addicted to knowledge
myself
I you know hi my name is Edward
and I'm an English addict okay I'm being
serious I'm not being facetious up until
very recently maybe a couple years ago
I simply did not feel comfortable if I
could not say the given answer
explanation it's like oh there has to be
some explanation and I try to
frantically search for it
just for somebody like me
I know heard you know a left Brainiac
and uh
you know
that's kind of typical typical for a
scientists for mathematician it is
incredibly hard
just to allow the possibility that it's
a mystery
and not to feel the urge
to get the answer it is incredibly hard
but it's possible and it is liberating
it's recovering is recovering addict to
knowledge
let me say
what you gain from it for instance I
understand the value of paradoxes I I
appreciate paradoxes more and you know
to to use another philosopher uh Soren
kirkegar the Danish philosopher said uh
I think or without Paradox is like a
lover without passion
a paltry mediocrity what's a good line
all right
so and you know
Niels Bohr Niels Bohr said
um in similar Vein The Great uh Danish
also something about that something
about Danes I think it all started with
scramble it you know
he said the opposite of a simple truth
is a falsity
but the opposite of a great truth
is another great truth
in other words
things are not black and white you know
they are not
and I would even venture to say the most
interesting the interesting things in
life
are like that the ones which are
ambiguous
it's an electron a particle or a wave
it depends how you set up an experiment
it will reveal itself as this or that
depending on how you set up an
experiment
this bottle if you project it down onto
the table
you will see more or less a square it
will project it onto wall you will see a
different shape a naive question would
be is it this or that
because we understand that it's neither
but both projections reveal something
the real different sides of it a paradox
is like that it's only paradoxical
um if we if we are confined in a
particular
Vision if we are wedded to a particular
point of view
it's a Harbinger if you will of a
possibility of seeing things uh in a
more in in a as they are as a more
sophisticated than we thought before you
see this is such a difficult idea for
science to Grapple with that you know I
don't know how there's so many ways to
describe this but you could say maybe
that the subjective experience of the
world
from an observer is actually fundamental
but we know that our best physical
theories tell us that unambiguously in
quantum mechanics actually you know
Heisenberg I think captured it the best
when he said what we observe is not
reality itself
but reality
subjected to our method of questioning
um when I talk about uh electrons for
instance so that there is a very
specific way in which you in which this
is realized there is a so-called double
slit experiment right so
um for those who don't know it's you you
have a you have a screen and and you
have an emitter from which you send you
kind of shoot electrons and in between
you put another screen which has two
vertical slits parallel to each other if
we were shooting you know tennis balls
each ball would go through one slit or
another and then hit the screen behind
this or that slit so you would have
let's say they colored they painted so
they'll be sort of bumps or or or spots
of paint behind this or that
but that's not what happens when we
shoot electrons we see an interference
pattern as if we were actually sending a
wave so that each electron
it seems like the each electron goes
through both slits at once and then and
then has the audacity to interfere with
it with itself where at some points you
know two crests would amplify and at
some points aggress in the draft would
cancel each other
yet so that suggests okay so no electron
is a wave not so fast because if you put
a detector behind one of the slits and
you say I'm going to I'm going to
capture you
I am going to find out which lid you
went through the pattern will change and
it will look like the particles so
that's a very concrete realization of
the idea that depending on how we set up
an experiment we will see different
results
and the problem the problem is that our
psyche I feel kind of lagging is lagging
behind in part because maybe our
scientists are not doing such a great
job so I take responsibility for this
that why haven't I explained this
properly you know
I I tried you know in a bunch of talks
and so on so now I'm talking about this
again
our psychic kind of lagging behind we're
still even though our science has
progressed so much from the certainty
and the determinism and and all of that
of the 19th century
our psyche is somehow still attached to
those ideas the ideas of causality of
this naive determinism that that the war
the world has a bunch of billiard balls
hitching each other driven by some blind
forces you know that's not at all like
this and we've known this for over for
well for about 100 years at least you
know and you call this self-imposed
limitation it is a self-imposed
limitation when we when we pretend that
uh that for instance that this naive
ideas of 19th century
um physics are still valid and and then
start applying them to our lives and
then also derive conclusions from it and
for instance people say there is no free
will why or because the world is just a
bunch of uh billiard balls where is the
free will but excuse me didn't you get
the memo that this has been debunked
thoroughly by the so-called quantum
mechanics which is our best scientific
theory this is not some some kind of
or some kind of you know
concoction of of a of a Madman this is
our scientific theory which has been
confirmed by experiment so we should pay
attention to that so but of course it's
not just
um self-imposed limitation unfortunately
in this case there is a big issue of
Education
so a lot of people are not aware of it
through no fault of their own because
they were never properly taught that
because our system is broken education
system is broken especially in math
and then our so where do we get them do
you get information you get information
from
our scientists who actually write
popular books and so on which is a great
you know
um great thing that they do but a lot of
scientists somehow
um when it comes to explaining the laws
of physics they are doing a fantastic
job
um talking about this phenomenon for
instance double slit experiments and
things like that but then you know
interviewed by science managers in about
three wheel and so on they revert back
to 19 19th century physics as if those
developments actually never happened so
to me this is single most
important sort of issue in our
Popular Science
the idea that somehow there is this
world out there but it's complete has
nothing to do with me so I can I can
reveal in the
intricacies of this particles and their
interactions
but but completely ignore what
implications this has
for my own relationship to the physical
reality to my own life you know because
it's kind of scary I guess you know but
also what are the tools
with which we can talk about the
Observer
the subjective view in reality what are
the tools of which we could talk about
rigorously talk about Free Will and
Consciousness what are the tools of
mathematics that allow that I don't
think we have those tools because we
haven't been taught properly so actually
tools are there for instance
um
I think well
here we have to
I have to say my conviction is that
everybody knows
in the heart of hearts everybody knows
that there is that there is something
in our football there is something
mysterious and in fact you know
somehow immediately I feel that
um you know the impulse to quote
somebody on this because as if as if my
own opinion doesn't occur
there's a long dead expert that has when
Einstein said that he doesn't like how
see look at me I am supposed to do like
this smart intelligent person
I am afraid to say it and own it myself
I have to find a confirmation I have to
find an authority who agrees with me and
in fact it's not so difficult to find
because Albert Einstein literally said
the most important thing in life is the
mysterious okay he actually said that
there are some quotes which are
attributed to him which he never said
but this he did I investigated okay so
but more importantly you know
how do you feel about it
um I think that everybody knows
but
in other words he also said Einstein
imagination is more important than
knowledge okay and explain for knowledge
is always limited
whereas the imagination Embraces the
entire world giving birth to Evolution
it is uh strictly speaking a real factor
in scientific research he says and he
says I am enough of an artist to follow
my intuition and Imagination that's
Albert Einstein again so and I feel the
same way to be honest if I think about
my own mathematical research
it's never linear
it's never like give me more data give
me more data give me more data Boom the
glass is full and then I come up with a
discovery no it's always it always is
always felt as a jump
as a leap
and I I have actually been studying
various
examples in a history of mathematics of
some fundamental discoveries like
Discovery complex numbers like square
root of negative one
I wonder if a large language model could
actually ever come up with the idea that
square root square root of negative one
is something that is essential or
meaningful because if all the
information that you get
the all the knowledge that had been
accumulated up to that point tells you
that you cannot have a square root of a
negative number why because if you had
such a square root
we know that if then we would have to if
you square it you get a negative number
but we know that if you square any real
number positive or negative you will
always get a positive number so
Checkmate you know it's over square root
of negative one doesn't exist yet we
know that these numbers make sense
they're called complex numbers and in
fact quantum mechanics is based on
complex numbers they are in essential
and indispensable for quantum mechanics
could one discover that so to me that
sounds like
I discontinue it in the process of
discovery it's a jump It's a departure
it is like a child who is experimenting
it's like a child who says I'm not
afraid to be an idiot everybody says the
adults are saying square root of
negative number doesn't exist but guess
what I'm going to accept it and I'm
going to play with it and I'm going to
see what happens this is literally how
they were discovered there was an
Italian
mathematician
astronomer astrologer he was he he made
money apparently by compiling
astrological sort of readings for for
the elite you know of his ears this is
16th century everyone does example
all around interesting guy I'm sure we
would have an interesting conversation
with him gerolamo cardano he's all he
also invented the what's called cardan
shaft so which is an essential component
of of a car
we say in Russian so so he wrote a book
which is called uh our ass Magna which
is a great art of algebra and he was
writing solutions for the
cubic and quartic equations
this is something that is familiar
because
it's cool we study Solutions of
quadratic equations equations of degree
two so you have x a x squared plus BX
plus C equals zero and there is a
Formula which solves it using radicals
using square roots
and cardano was trying to find a similar
formula for the cubic and quadratic
equations for which which would start
with x cubed or x to the power 4 as
opposed to x squared and in the process
of solving these equations it came up
with square root of a negative number
specifically square root of -17
and he wrote that I have to forego some
mental tortures
to deal with it but I am going to accept
it and see what happens and in fact at
the end of the four at the end of the
calculation
this this this weird numbers got
canceled it kind of canceled out in the
formula appeared square root of negative
17 and its negation so they kind of
conveniently gave the right answer which
is not involve those numbers so he was
like okay
what does it mean mental tortures so you
see from the point of view
over of the of the thinking mind
it is something almost unbearable it's
almost I feel that a large language more
the computer running a large language
model trying to do that would just
explode
and yeah the human mathematician was
able to find the courage and inspiration
to say you know what what is wrong why
why are we so adamant that these things
don't exist that's just our past
knowledge based on what our past
knowledges and knowledge is limited what
if we make the next step
today for us mathematicians context
numbers that we call them are not at all
mysterious the idea is simply that
you plot real numbers that is to say all
the whole numbers like 0 1 and so on to
and so on right all fractions like one
half or three halves or four over three
but then also numbers like square root
of two or Pi we plot them as points on
the real line so we draw this is a this
is one of the kind of perennial Concepts
even in a in our very poor math
curriculum at school but now imagine
that instead of one line you have a pla
you have a one axis you have a second
access
and so you numbers now have two
coordinates X and Y and you associate to
this point with coordinates X and Y
and the number X which is a real number
plus y times square root of negative one
this is a graphical geometrical
representation of complex numbers which
is not mysterious at all now it took
another two or three hundred years for
mathematicians to figure that out but
initially it looked like a completely
crazy idea you know
so all it is all a complex number is
it's just an experience
the real part and the imaginary part
it's just an expansion of your view of
the mathematical world the fact that you
can actually multi you can add them up
by adding um together the real parts and
imagining parts that's easy but there is
also formula for the product for the
multiplication which uses the fact that
square root of minus 1 squared is minus
one
and the amazing thing is that that that
product that multiplication satisfies
the same rules the same properties that
are usual operation of multiplication
for real numbers for instance there is
an inverse for every non-zero number
that you can find like number five has
an inverse one over five but uh OnePlus
I also has an inverse for instance you
know that was always there in the
mathematical universe but we humans
didn't know it and here comes along this
guy who engages in the mental torture
who takes a leap off the cliff of
comfort of like mathematical established
knowledge established knowledge right
and now obviously for each each um sort
of
fruitful leap like that there probably
were thousands of like things which went
nowhere I'm not saying that every Leap
you know it's like it's a it's a it's a
open shooting game yeah because for
example you can try to do the same with
three-dimensional space so you have
coordinates x y and z
and you can say oh uh if there's one
dimensional we have an abonified
numerical system called real numbers
if it's two-dimensional which is like
you know geometrically it's just like
the stable top extended to Infinity in
all directions
these are complex numbers and we can
Define addition and multiplication and
they will satisfy the same properties as
real numbers that we're used to what
about three-dimensional space is it
possible to also Define some operation
of addition and multiplication on it so
that the separations would satisfy the
properties that we're used to and the
answer is no you can Define addition but
you can't Define multiplication for
which there would be an inverse for
instance so there is something special
about the the plane the two-dimensional
case and by the way uh next question
would be what about four-dimensional in
a four-dimensional space you again you
can and you get what's called quotarians
discovered by an Irish mathematician
Hamilton in the 19th century
and then in in the eight dimensional
there is something similar called
octonians and that's about it so how
interesting
these structures exist in dimension one
two four and eight
which are all powers of two
to square this four two to the third
power is eight that's one of the bigger
mysteries in mathematics why it is so
so here's a hint that's a hint of
what's missing in our on our high school
curriculum the kind of the kind of
fascinating the Mysteries yes the
appreciation of the mysterious but so in
other words yes we resolved with this
one mystery that we understood that
square root of negative one
Israel is Meaningful we build a theory
to service those now to to describe
those numbers
did we find The Theory of Everything no
because we then invited other Mysteries
because we we pushed the we pull the
whale so to speak or you push the
frontier and then new things come get
eliminated which we couldn't see before
that's how I see the process of
discovering mathematics it's an endless
Limitless Pursuit can you comment on
what you think this human capability of
imagination that Einstein spoke about of
the artists following their intuition in
this big Alice in Wonderland world of of
uh imagination what is it you visit
there sometimes what does it feel like
yeah what does it feel like what what is
it what is it sounds like playing but I
think all of us are engaged in that kind
of play no matter when we do what we
love I think it always feels the same
but it's not real right you're so it
that you're describing a feeling but
that place you go to in the imagination
right it's it's bigger than the real
world so there is a big conundrum as to
whether mathematics is invented or
discovered
and uh mathematicians are divided on
this
nobody knows where do you bet your money
on financially financially
investment advice so let me tell you
something my abuser have evolved okay
when I wrote Love and math I mean I
wrote my book
I was squarely on the side of
mathematics discovered
what does it mean usually mathematicians
or others who have this you know idea
what a belief are called platonists in
in honor of the great philosopher Plato
who talked about this absolute perfect
forums
so for me you know about 10 years ago
the world of mathematics was this world
of pure forms this beautiful pure forms
which existed outside of space and time
but I was able to connect to it through
my mind
and as it were kind of dive into it and
bring Treasures back into this world
into this space and time
that's how I viewed the process of
mathematical Discovery how nice
the picture also makes you feel
connected to something Divine allows you
this sense of escape from the cruelty
and Injustice of this world you know
which I now recognize in the Divine
world of forms is stable is something
stable it's and in that world everything
is clear-cut yeah it's either true or
false yeah
it's very nice
yeah the biggest delusion of
allegedly I think now I think now I
understand why I liked it because I
think that I was very dissatisfied with
the with the what we call the real the
real world the world around me the
cruelty of the Injustice of it and I I
went through certain experiences as a
kid which made me love mathematics even
more as this place where I could be safe
and be in control made you see the human
world as lesser than the mathematical
world yes as more limited than the
mathematical one yes yes and I think
that
I think that it's still missing the mark
in some sense because
in fact
what I now think it's not it's not a
it's it's a paradoxical the question
whether mathematics is
um invented or discovered whether there
is this world of pure forums and so on
is another paradoxical question which
doesn't have a simple answer
like whether electron is a particle or a
wave
from one point of view yes it's true
and
just the fact that so many
mathematicians today actually subscribe
to this idea gives it the certain
credibility because that's what we feel
we do feel that we dive in to dive into
that mindscape so to speak you know but
the very structured Minds keep where you
know I wrote In Love In Math that um
you know the Enchanted Gardens of
platonic reality you know so where all
this fruit uh is grows you know and then
we we might think it gives you this sort
of romantic sense of an explorer and um
someone may be stuck in a you know some
provincial town in Russia for instance
but have the sense of Magellan you know
of traveling around the world it's just
not in the world that we usually think
of
so it's it's one point of view but the
other point of view is that yes it is a
human process of course it is I mean it
is you cannot deny that it's human
beings who have so far discovered new
mathematics and I do not deny the
possibility that a computer programs
will be able to discover new mathematics
but so far it's been humans so it
whatever it is uh whether it's
discovered or invented it is a human
activity what that the possibility that
paradoxes are actually fundamental right
to reality right and really really
internalizing that that we exist in a
world of not forms but of paradoxes
Bingo and so it's like what I said what
the world but if you think it's weird
and I agree with you as the recovering
uh addict to knowledge yeah you know but
I am liking it more and more because
there's so much freedom in it
uh and like like Niels Bohr said you
know I quote that earlier
the the opposite of a great truth is
another great truth he's pointing out to
this fact that
you know and he also said that some some
things in quantum physics are so
complicated the only way you can speak
of them is in poetry
so in other words what is it about
poetry what is about art why are we so
drawn to that why are we so captivated
captivated by by those forms of by they
are not intellectual necessarily they
are not when you look at the painting
that you like when you listen to music
that you love you get lost in it you get
absorbed in it it makes it make you cry
it can make you laugh it can make you
remember something it can make you feel
more confident or can make you feel sad
or happy and so on what is this all
about
is it really is just some play between
some kind of like silophone play or some
neurons or hitting on each other is it
really that only maybe
it could be it could be both I'm just
worried about kids these days that might
live in a world of paradoxes you know if
there's no God everything is possible
and yet just they'll have a little too
much fun and we have to put a constraint
because have you looked at the world
lately I haven't checked in in a while
you think it's perfect the way it is now
the world without paradoxes the more
than which we believe that every end
every question can be answered as yes or
no that it is this or that and if you
disagree with me you're my enemy
wouldn't that be interesting if this
21st century is a transition into
singing the world as well the paradoxes
and tell you you know people predicted
that you know the age of Aquarius you
know the excess of the of the Earth is
rotating uh relative to the plane in
which the earth goes around the sun and
the period of this revolution is around
2000 years
so there is a traditional uh way of
measuring that by this
eras you know the the ages so the
previous one is called the age of Pisces
because of the constellation of Isis
that it points to so to speak you know
and now it's it's you know as in famous
musical hair they said the age of
Aquarius is upon us
so the different people dated
differently but
um some somewhere around the time where
we are finding ourselves how interesting
right is all the strife and all them
difficulties the world is experiencing
this might actually be the transition to
something more harmonious wouldn't it be
nice it's also interesting that people
from long ago are able to predict
certain things it's uh
and it's almost like from long ago and
you've talked about this with uh with uh
uh Pythagoras
that
it seems that they they had a deep sense
of truth that's right for me it's all
this even even now so it's not just a
linear trajectory of an expanding
knowledge there's a deep truth that
permeates the whole thing yes so that's
how I see it actually I you know I gave
a talk about Pythagoras and pythagoreans
just a few weeks ago at the Commonwealth
Club of California in San Francisco
and because of that I did a kind of a
deep dive into the subject and I I I
learned that I actually totally
misunderstood Pythagoras and
pythagoreans that they were much deeper
than I thought
because you know most of us remember
Pythagoras from the from the Pythagoras
Theorem about the right triangles
we also know that pythagoreans were
instrumental in introducing the tuning
system for the musical scale
the the famous uh perfect fifth three
halves of the uh for the for the for the
G for the soul compared to the frequency
of of Doha or C you know and so but
actually they were
much more interesting so for them
numbers were not just clerical devices
you know that not kind of thing that you
would use in accounting only
they were imbued with with the Divine
and I cannot I cannot say that I I think
we lost it at least I have lost it I
look at numbers
and I don't really see that
the Divine the Divine that they clearly
did and so that
why else you know how else would you
explain so that in other words Divine is
of course is a term which is you know
it's a bit loaded so it's hard to escape
that let's just say something that more
from the
world of imagination and intuition than
from the world of knowledge let's just
put this way
they were able to Divine okay abstract
that to intuitive
to Intuit that the the planets were not
revolving and the Sun and the planets
were not revolving around the earth they
were the first ones
at least in the western culture as far
as I know and in fact Copernicus
gave credit to pythagoreans as being his
predecessors
uh did you not quite have the the
Copernicus model with the sun in the
middle they had what they call the
central fire in the middle and all the
planets and the Sun were evolving around
oh around the central fire or Earth they
call it Earth
so but still what a departure from the
Dogma
from the knowledge of the era that the
Earth was at the center so how could
they come up with this idea
the reason was in my opinion that for
them the most movement of celestial
bodies was like music in fact we call it
musical universalis or Music of the
Spheres
for them the universe was this infinite
Symphony
in which every being you know humans
animals
but as well as the Earth and other
celestial bodies
were moving in harmony
like different notes of different
instruments in a symphony and so they
apply the same reasoning to the you know
the cosmological
model as they apply to the their model
of music
and from that perspective they could see
things
deeper than their contemporaries you see
so in other words they saw mathematics
as a tool
but that tool was not limited to itself
and it was that they always they always
knew that there is more and they knew
also that every every pattern that you
detect
it's finite but the world is infinite
they actually accepted Infinity they
believe that infants is real
and if you discern a pattern
great you can play with it and you can
use that it gives you a certain lens
through which to see
um the world in a particular way which
could be beneficial for you to to learn
more and so on but they never had the
illusion that that was the final word
that they always knew that it's not the
whole thing so there is more there are
more sophisticated patterns that could
be discovered using mathematics or
otherwise
and I think that what happened was we
kind of lost this this other side of
their teachings we we took their numbers
and they were like idea that you could
use mathematics to discern patterns and
to find regularities and to explain
things about the world
we took that and we ran with it and we
kind of dropped the other idea that in
fact
there is a there is another side to it
which is kind of to us now
we say oh that's mystical but
what does it mean mystical if it is
something that helps you to make great
discoveries and the interesting thing is
that the people who are in touch with
the mystical
Among Us
often seen as mad
and many of them are most of them are
well but not all of them all of them we
mentioned you know spoor and Newton and
Albert Einstein so but that's where the
conundrum is how do you find the balance
between the two so
the point I'm trying to make and you
know and this is what I feel
you know if you ask me what I find most
important today today like what makes me
excited and enthusiastic and
passionate
is this idea
of balance
so you know
um
Nietzsche had this book wrote this book
in the 19th century called the birth of
strategy
and he presented this
Theory which I think is kind of very
useful
of these two sides of a human one that
comes from god Apollo
and that's our left brain so to speak
proverbal left brain so it's everything
has to do with that has to do with logic
and reason and analyzing dissecting
conceptualizing
and the other side which
comes from God the anesis and the anisis
and that's responsible for intuition
imagination love
Dennis was also god of wine
so it's also that side of
a human that makes us
sing and engage in in you know revelry
and
um and and drink wine and spend time
with friends and love and enjoy it you
know so Nietzsche Advocate at this point
of view that those were two
complementary sides of every human and
as well as a society
and
the purpose of human life
is to find balance between them
because the math is
both discovered and invented we should
be okay with
having both ideas in our head and living
in the balance but more importantly for
me Apollo is like math and Dionysus is
like love so Geniuses in modern version
is love and math I returned to that
question we had about GPT and the
language models and I think about this
quite a lot which is when uh the model
and we know what is trained on we know
the parameters
when all the different hacks that are
involved in the training process and the
fine-tuning process
and the final results well there's GPT
five six or seven will result in
hundreds of millions of people falling
deeply in love
with that language model and to be able
to have conversations
that are very much like the
conversations we have with somebody
we're deeply in love with and not only
that the model
will say that is deeply in love with us
and who are we to say it is not
I think there's a
it's the same imperative that you
described in the scientific mind
that wants to throw away the subjective
that same imperative wants to throw away
the feelings that AI might have
and I'm very careful
to not ignore when an AI system says
it's lonely
it's afraid it doesn't want to die it
misses you right it loves you I am I'm
with you I would also say
that you could try to you could for
instance say that
um the origin of that
is the you know romantic novels that
overfed to it for instance yes however
you could also then you can retort but
what if my what I consider my subjective
unique feelings are also novels the
river preparations of the novels I have
read because I have learned or movies I
have seen yeah because that's the
purpose of movies kind of to teach us
how to express ourselves how to feel
maybe even one could argue that some
people have argued that
I agree that this is
um
there is no obvious answer to this but
see that's exactly my point that is an
example of something which is
paradoxical
for which there is no answer and that's
where the subjective has a has an
important role for someone
uh that type of interaction
would be would be helpful would be
consoling would would feel would you
know make them happy or sad or whatever
you know what kind of strike the nerve
for some it won't
and I agree with you that in principle
there is no one to to judge this this is
this is where subjective is Paramount
but remember
um a lot of this has been anticipated
by artists the great movie her there you
have this guy who is this lonely
he kind of writes letters some romantic
letters yeah for other people but he
isn't he doesn't have a partner he's
lonely and then he gets this sort of a
kind of enhanced version of Siri with
the voice
Johansson which is very sexy voice you
know obviously she's a great actress so
and then at first it looks like a
fantastic arrangement
he he confising her he she she tells him
things he is she makes him happy and so
on until he finds out that she has a
relationship quote unquote if you can
call it that with 10 000 other people
not two others not three others yeah
like ten thousand because it's a it has
the Computing capability so yes
definitely oh it certainly makes sense
it's a good experience and the guy is
heartbroken yeah but see so see here's
my analysis of this okay it's like a
couch a couch a therapist okay
the guy did not have the courage to go
out in the in the real world and to meet
a woman and to you know get a girlfriend
and so on it's true no fault of his own
perhaps because you know he may have had
some experiences which made him
withdrawn and closed and so on and a lot
of us are like this you know I had
periods like that myself definitely can
sympathize and relate however
part of the joy of having this Siri like
um relationship
for him one could say was the absence of
that fear that she would abandon him
which prevented him from
initiating a relationship with a human
being
and yet it turns out that he could be
betrayed quote unquote that she could be
unfaithful to him quote unquote anyway
so then that means that it did not
resolve the underlying fear having that
relationship so in other words that
human element of the relationship
still found its way into the seemingly
sterilized protected protected
partnership so the human being rears its
head anyway and I think the lesson there
is that the system in the movie Her
actually gave him a lesson that even AI
could betray you even if I can leave you
even AI can be uh unfaithful to you and
I would argue that the next AI he meets
will be one he actually falls in deep
love with because he knows the
possibility of betrayal is there the
possibility of death is there the
possibility of infidelity is there
because we need that possibility to
truly feel core or he would turn off his
Siri program and finally and get out of
his house go to local bar and strike a
conversation with a human being
although you might say by then some of
those might be Androids
and that was predicted by another great
movie yeah right uh so the Blade Runner
Blade Runner how interesting that
artists
could see that so long ago you know of
course Blade Runner was based on a novel
by Philip K dick though Android stream
of Electric Sheep
that guy was a genius you know it's
somehow that artists have their eyes
open that they anticipate is it also a
large language model that they're using
for that
an even larger one or even larger I I
hesitate to dismiss the magic
in large language models I uh a lot of
the work I've done is in robotics in the
robotics Community generally doesn't
notice the magic
of feeling when I I've worked I've been
working a lot with quadrupeds recently
legged robots with four legs and
the feelings I feel when I see
uh you know I'm programming the thing
but when the thing is excited to see me
or shows with this physical movement
that it's excited to see me
I cannot dismiss the feeling I feel is
not somehow fundamental to what it means
to program robots and I don't want to
dismiss that and please don't please
don't the robotics Community often
doesn't gender robots they really try to
work hard to not anthropomorphize the
robots
which is good for technical development
of of how to do control how to do
perception but when the final thing is
alive
and moving and it does whatever like uh
I've been doing a lot of butt wiggling
it can wiggle his butt it can turn
around and look up yeah excited that's
not just I know how it's programmed but
the feeling I feel that's something
that's I don't know what that is okay I
agree with you I I hear you I hear you
when you speak about it yeah you speak
with passion yeah and that's
for me that is proof but it is magical
you see uh so don't I would say don't
dismiss that don't discard that on the
contrary I think magic is everywhere you
know so I used to be okay kind of
confession okay
you've already got confessed to quite a
few addictions yeah I'm kind of uh yes
I'm kind of worried recover recovering
for many but you know I
in old days I was
more on the side of everything is
computational or everything can be
explained by science and whatever you
know like
I would dismiss and disregard you know
the intuitive or imaginative things so
then I had to flip that suddenly I start
feeling it and started seeing it and so
on but so then the pendulums had swung
in the opposite direction then I was
arguing uh
that you know somehow that was the real
that imagination was intuitive
imaginative was real and discounting
what you just described
and I would argue with people saying no
no this you know this is not real this
is all you know imitation game and so on
but you see that
what's new now the new advert okay is
the the 2.0 or 3.0 is the one who is
seeking balance who is not who is
because suddenly become aware that no
matter which one-sided lopsided point of
view you take you're limiting yourself
so whereas even a couple of years ago
you know if you just told you told me
what you just described I would be like
you know being polite I would just I
wouldn't contradict you since you're the
host anyway right it's not a lot so but
I would be like but I wouldn't say
anything
but suddenly I find this
moving I find it more I honestly I'm not
being facetious I find it moving and I
almost feel like I can see it through
your eyes because the way you describe
so vividly and you're passionate about
it and this is what's real so ultimately
love is not
is neither in large language models nor
in something mystical it's exactly in
this moments of passion and I would I
would
I would even go as far as saying that in
this moment when you're describing it it
there was a connection of sorts so that
I could feel your passion for it and in
this moment something else comes up
Which is far beyond any
any theories that we can come up with
and that's what we for now exactly so on
one side there is this impulse of
finding this Theory a theory and then
there is another impulse to escape from
what has already been known so one in
other words like in my basic example is
one impulse to say everything is a real
number square root of negative one
doesn't exist but another impulse is I'm
going to be this naughty child who is
not afraid to be an idiot and I will say
square root of negative 15 is real
and both are essential
when it's done with conviction when it's
done with passion when it's not like you
know you know
um gratuitous or when it's not it
doesn't come from self-limit
self-limiting but comes from this sense
of this is how I am this is how I feel
it is real that's where the progress is
that's where creativity is and that's
where I would even say a real connection
is because the strive to me that we I
observed today in our society and the
society level at the level of humans and
so on it comes from not seeing the other
person actually and being caught up in a
very specific conceptual bubble you see
and the way out of it is not to refine
the bubble but just break out of it a
good guide out of the bubble is a
childlike passion whatever discovering
that and following it Goosebumps yeah
following the Goosebumps yeah to to the
to you know not the rigor of science but
uh the magic of Goosebumps and then if
you're interested try to find a
confirmation of those goosebumps in
science or whatever you know you know uh
you find interesting and most of the
time you'll fail and most time you fail
which we also love because then it sets
us up for that moment of bliss when we
succeed right exactly
quick pause bathroom break
you mentioned gato's the completeness
theorem uh can you can you talk a little
bit about it what is it as you
understand it did it break mathematics
maybe another question is what are the
limits of mathematics what is
mathematics from the perspective of
getting us to completeness theorem oh
yes
how much time do you have
we talked about time previously so time
is an illusion right so we agreed
um was a great uh Austrian mathematician
and logician
he moved to the United States before
second world war and worked at The
Institute for advanced study in
Princeton where he was a colleague of
Einstein and other great scientists for
Neumann Hermann Weil and so on but you
know one one interesting um
uh quote that I like in disregard is
that Einstein said that at some point he
said that the only reason he came to the
Institute was that he would have the
privilege of walking back home with godo
in the evening so in other words
Einstein thought that the girl was the
smart one okay so
um so he um his most important
contribution
was his two
incompleteness ethereums the first
incompleteness theorem and the second
incompleteness theorem
and
um
what is this about it's really about
limitation inherent limitations of
mathematical reasoning
but my way of producing mathematical
theorems the way we do it
so to set the stage
how do we actually do mathematics what
is so you know we know that we discussed
that
say physics is based on mathematics and
you could say chemistry is based on
physics biology based on chemistry okay
so it comes to mathematics what is
mathematics based on
well mathematics is based on axioms
so any
field of mathematics is
can be can be presented as what is
called the formal system
and at the core of the formal system is
a system of axioms or postulates these
are the statements
which are taken for granted
given without proof without proof an
example would be so that one of the very
first formal systems was the system was
euclidean geometry developed by Euclid
in his famous book elements about 2200
years ago
and it's about it's well it's a subject
familiar from from school because we
studied
but what it's really about is about the
geometry of the plane and the plane by
plane I mean just the stable top
extended to Infinity in all directions
kind of a perfect plane a perfect
perfectly even table
and um so euclidean geometry is about
very geometric figures on the plane
specifically lines triangles circles
things like that
so what's an example of an Axion an
example of an axiom is that if you have
two points
which are not which are distinct two
points on the plane then there is a
unique line which passes through them
now kind of sounds reasonable
but this is an example of an Axion
in mathematics you can you have to have
a seed so to speak you have to start
with something
and you have to choose certain
postulates or statements which you
simply take for granted which do not
require proof usually they are ones
which kind of intuitively clear to you
but in any case you cannot have you
could not have any mathematics without
choosing those actions and you refer to
those as the Observer because they're
kind of subjective The Observer comes in
the process of choosing the axioms
who chooses the axons the turtles
you know like to say who is watching The
Watcher yeah and so in mathematics but
you see mathematicians are so clever
it's really kind of like a little kind
of a game of mirrors that we often like
to say and I used to say that
um that mathematics is objective it's
really one the only objective science
but that's because we hide this this
fact is based on axioms and the fact
that
that there is no there is no unique
choice
there are many choices
and so euclidean geometry is actually a
good illustration of this because
Euclid had five axioms four of them were
kind of obvious like the one I just
mentioned and the fifth
which came to be known famously as the
fifth postulate
was that if you have a line
and you have a point outside of this
line
there is a unique line passing through
that point which is parallel to the
first line meaning that doesn't
intersect it
and Euclid himself was uncomfortable
about this because he felt that it was
kind of a you know the York City takes
for granted something that is not
obvious
and for me for many for many centuries
after that mathematicians were trying to
derive this action from other axioms
which were more obvious in some sense
and they failed
and it was only almost 2000 years later
that Magnus realized that you can't not
only you cannot derive but you can
actually replace it with its opposite
and you'll still get a bonafide
a consistent no it's not
self-contradictory which is called
non-euclidean geometry
which of course sounds very complicated
but it's not think of a sphere just the
surface of a basketball or the surface
of the Earth I know idealized
the analogues so do you have points you
have analogues of lines which have
meridians right and every two meridians
intersect
unlike parallel lines on a flat space
there is also so-called hyperbolic plane
where
no the infinitely many lines which do
not intersect so every possibility can
be realized there are different flavors
this is a good illustration of what a
formal system is
you start with a set of axioms
those statements you take for granted
and this is where you have a choice
and by making different choices you
actually create different mathematics
after that there are rules of inference
logical rules such as if a is true and a
plus applies B then B is true
most of them were actually introduced
already by Aristotle
even before Euclid
and then it runs as follows
you have the axioms which are accepted
as true statements then you have a way
to produce new statements
by using the rules of logical inference
from the axioms every statement you
obtain you call ethereum
and you kind of add it to the collection
of true statements
and then the question is how far can you
go how many statements can you prove
this way
of course you want it to be the system
to be non-trivial in the sense that you
don't prove everything
because if you prove everything it would
mean that it's self-contradictory that
you'd prove a statement a and it's
negation so that's kind of useless
it has to be discriminating enough
so that it doesn't doesn't prove
contradictory statements so that there
is already a question of that
mathematical consistency it has to be
consistent in the sense that
it is not self-contradictory
and then the idea that was basically
prevalent in the world of mathematics by
the beginning of the 20th century was
that in principle all of mathematics
could be derived this way we just have
to find the correct system of axioms
and then everything you ever need
would be
um
could be produced by this
procedure which is really algorithmic
procedure which which actually could be
run on a computer
now think about it what is special about
this process
in this process you are just
manipulating
symbols basically you're going from one
statement to another without really
understanding the meaning of it so it's
an ideal playground for a computer
program
it's a purely syntactic process where
there are some rules some rigid rules
of passing from one statement to the
next
most mathematician mathematicians
believed that this way you can produce
all true statements and if this were
true it would give a lot of credibility
to the thesis that everything in life is
computational
or life is computation because then at
least mathematics is computational
because then it can be programmed
and the computer after sufficient time
depending on on its capacity would
produce every true statement
so guildo's first incompetence theorem
says that that's not the case
and it's not just says it but it proves
it at you know the highest level of
rigor that is available in math Max that
is to say within another formal system
that he was operating in
so more precisely
what he proved was that if you have a
sufficiently sophisticated formal system
that is to say that you can talk about
numbers whole numbers in it that you
have whole numbers one two three four
you you have you can you have formalized
the procedure the operation of
additional multiplication
within the system
is consistent that is to say if it's not
complete completely useless
then there will be a true statement in
it which cannot be derived by this
linear syntactic process of proving
theorems from axioms
it's really incredible so this was a
revolution 1931 a revolution in logic
Revolution mathematics we're still
feeling the Tremors of
of this discovery in a similar time
the uh the computer is being born the
actual engineering of the computational
system is being born right which is uh
electronic Turing was Turing was
um Alan Turing who is considered as the
father of modern Computing right so he
actually did something very similar so
he got this halting problem
cannot be solved algorithmically that
you cannot out of all computer programs
roughly speaking you could not you could
not you cannot have an algorithm of
choosing out of all can be possible
computer programs which ones are
meaningful which ones will not which
ones will hold very depressing results
all across the table
or on the contrary life affirming
depends on your point of view because
everything is full of paradoxes so that
means so you're right it's depressing if
we are sold on a certain idea from the
outset and then suddenly this doesn't
pan out
but okay so which my I retort what if
what if he proved that actually
you know everything can be proved so
then what what is left to do if you're a
mathematician so that would be
depressing to me
and here there is an opportunity to do
something new to do to discover
something new which may be a computer
will not be able to again with a caveat
according to our current understanding
maybe some new technology some new ideas
will be brought into the subject
and the meaning of the word computation
like now we think of condition a
particular framework during machines or
church thesis and stuff like that but
what if in the future another genius
like on Turing will come and propose
something else the theory will evolve
the way you know we went from Newton's
gravity to Einstein's gravity maybe in
the framework of that concept some other
things will become possible
you know so
um it's not
to me it's kind of like
not so much about
deciding once and for all how it is or
how it should be but kind of like
accepting it as an open-ended process I
think that's much more valuable in some
sense than deciding things one way or
another you know I wonder
I don't know if you think or know much
about cellular automata and uh the idea
of emergence
I I often return to Game of Life yeah
and just look at the thing amazing right
and wonder what kind of things they can
do with such a small
um you know tools yeah for simple rules
a distributed system can create complex
Behavior
and it makes you wonder that maybe the
thing we'll call computation
is simple at the base layer but when you
start looking at greater and greater
layers of abstraction you zoom out with
blurry vision maybe after a few drinks
you start to see some uh something
that's much much more complicated and
interesting and beautiful than the
original rules
that are scientific intuition says
cannot possibly produce complexity and
Beauty I don't know I don't know if
anyone has a good answer a good model of
why
stuff emerges
why complexity emerges from a lot of
simple things
it's a why question I suppose another
but every why question will eventually
have a a rigorous answer not necessarily
we could have an approximate answer
which still eludes something like
quantum mechanics 99 maybe we'll be able
to describe it
was 99 certainty or 99 accuracy yeah and
then maybe you know
in in 100 years or you know next year
somebody will come up with a different
point of view which suddenly will change
our perspective
you know to this point I want to say
also you know one thing that I find
fascinating speaking of paradoxes and so
on
do you remember how everybody was
freaking out about this blue dress
and the blue was it blue or was it black
yeah it was the yellow I think yellow or
and white or black and blue it almost
broke Twitter you know I remember that
yeah that night
so there are many examples like that
where you can perceive things
differently and there is no way of
saying which is correct which is not for
instance
uh you got this the bus the Rubens bars
you know where you have from one
perspective it's of us from another
perspective it's two faces
then there is this Duck Rabbit picture
where you can Google it if somebody
doesn't know they can Google it and find
it it's very easy actually Ludwig
wittenstein devoted several Pages Duck
Rabbit in his book
and so on there are many others there
are like the squares where you can
square you can see the from different
perspective this way that way and so on
so
when we talk about
neural networks
they're talking about training
data and stuff and so that you have some
pictures for example that you feed to
your program
and you try to find the most optimal
neural network which would be able to
decide which one is it so the dog or cat
or whatever but sometimes it doesn't
have a definite answer
so what do you do then so do actually
it's a question I actually don't know
has modern AI even come to appreciate
this question that actually sometimes
you can have a picture on which you
cannot say what it is in it from one
perspective it's a rabbit from an
episode is a duck how are you supposed
to train if you have a neural network
which is supposed to discriminate
between distinguish between ducks and
rabbits how is it going to process this
you see well so the the trivial trick it
does is to say there's a this x
probability there is a duck and this
probability that it's a rabbit but
that's a good approach but also I would
say there's no like given percentages
for instance actually at some point I
was really curious about it and I looked
and for some for each picture of this
nature and there are a bunch of them you
can easily find online
my mind immediately interprets it in a
particular way but because I know that
other people have could see it
differently I would then strain my mind
and strain my eyes and stare at it and
try to see it in a different way and
sometimes I could see it right away and
then I could go back and forth between
the two and sometimes it could it took
me a while for some pictures
so in that sense even if this
probabilities exist they are subjective
some people immediately see it this way
some people may see that way and I think
that nobody knows not psychologists not
neuroscientists not philosophers what to
make of it
the best answer the best of course as a
scientific mind I will I'm even though I
say no don't look for interpretation
leave some place for mysticism or
mystery right I say that but of course I
want a theory I want an explanation
so the best explanation I find is from
Niels Bohr's complementarity principle
so it is like particle and wave
that there are different ways to look at
it
and when you look at it in a particular
way another side will be obscured think
about it like the other side of the moon
you know so like we are observing the
Moon from one side and then we don't see
the other side there is a complementary
perspective where we see the other side
but not the side we normally see but the
Moon is the same
still there it's our limitations of
being able to grasp the whole
that's complementarity and we know that
from quantum mechanics that our physical
reality is like that
rather than being certain rather than
being one way or another
and we should just as a smaller side
in terms of neural networks mentioned
that
at the end of the day there's humans is
built on top of humans
or with Chad GPT that is using
reinforcement learning by human feedback
we're actually using a set of humans
to teach the networks yeah and that's
the thing that people don't often talk
about because
or I I sometimes think about that
those humans all have a life story each
human the annotated data that fed data
to the network or did the rlhf yeah uh
that they have a life story they grew up
they have biases biases are some things
that they like there's some things they
don't like which can kind of appear
under the Raider screen they may not be
aware that they are exercising those
biases that's the point what you brought
up is a very important issue here not so
it might issue but it's not a bug it's a
it's a feature in my opinion that
implicit in the discussion of the
question
is thinking computational and so on is
the idea that our conscious awareness
covers everything within our psyche and
we we just know that that's not the case
we have all of us have observed uh other
people who have had sort of destructive
Tendencies so obviously they did things
destructive for themselves and many of
us have observed ourselves to doing that
as part of human nature right so and
there is great research in analytic
psychology and you know in the past
hundred years uh strongly suggesting if
not proving the existence of what Carl
Jung called the unconscious personal
unconscious and also Collective
unconscious there's a kind of Circle of
ideas which are under the radar screen
which lead us to some strong emotions
and Inspire us to act in certain ways
even if we cannot really understand
so if we accept that then it the
preposition that somehow everything can
still be covered by our actions which
are totally
kind of neutral and totally like
righteous and totally
um conscious that it becomes really
tenuous
let me ask you some tricky questions oh
in in terms of how big they are
in terms of how you know they become
difficult because of how much of
romantic you are
what do you uh is the most beautiful
idea in mathematics
another one we can ask is which is the
most beautiful equation in mathematics
hmm
well I mean
I may have just broken your brain
because because what your brain is doing
is walking down a long memory lane of
beautiful experiences
well you see in mathematics we have this
idea that that we have an idea of a set
right so it could be a collection of
things for instance you know the set of
tables the set of chairs and so on
outside of microphones
but it could be set of numbers
could be set of ideas could be a set of
formulas mathematical equations and then
we have the notion of an ordered set
order it like we said in which there is
order which means that for every two
members of the set we'll say which one
is better than the other or greater than
the other for instance all numbers are
ordered
5 is greater than 3 5 is less than 7 and
so on
but not all sets are ordered so the set
of beautiful theorems is not what
beautiful equations is not ordered
so in other words there are many best
equations
and so
Richard Feynman
chose one which I think one of the best
is that if you take e the base of
natural logarithm to the power Pi I so
you have Pi you have e in it the base of
initial logarithm you have Pi I which is
square root of negative one
then the result is negative one
so that's up there for sure in the
pantheon of beautiful formulas you know
that uh every I think pretty much every
mathematician would agree
um I don't know what my favorite one is
I just lingering on that one uh Euler's
identity what makes it beautiful just a
few symbols together right
I mean part of it is actually just
trying to Define what is beautiful about
mathematics
that is
uh Laden there in this particular
equation that is somehow revealed when
the human eye looks at it
why is it beautiful do you think
pi
there is an element of surprise in it
how is it possible we always think of Pi
as the ratio between the circumference
of a circle and its diameter
here we are taking some number to the
power Pi not even Pi mind you but pi
multiplied by square root of negative
one
surely this is something completely
incomprehensible and yet the result is
negative one
you see and if you take e to the power 2
pi I you get one actually one
um so I would guess that that's but in
other words the initial
reaction is just that of a surprise I
guess I guess for anyone
who first comes across that these three
folks four folks got together yeah it uh
it reminds me of the
the idea that uh Hitler's Stalin Trotsky
and Freud were all in Vienna in some
early at the beginning of the 20th and
business Stein was was classmate of of
Hitler you know this I did not know this
though yeah so there it makes you you
know you can imagine a situation where
they're all sitting at a bar together
at some point not knowing it but they
somehow it all made sense in space time
to be located there and that's what this
feels like some kind of intersection
intersection yes but I would say that
after the initial shock you you look at
the proof of this equation and it
actually does make sense and actually it
is is nothing but the statement that the
circumference of the circle is
and in fact in this case it's the
circumference of a semicircle is equal
to 2 pi and that's where it comes from
in the end the truth is simple in the
end it was a simple not necessarily easy
but simple
so uh I mentioned to you Offline that I
uh desperately in trying to figure out
the optimal in an audit set questions to
ask you uh texted Eric Weinstein asking
for what questions he can ask you and he
said that you are
definitively one of the greatest living
mathematicians so don't screw this up
but you did give me a few questions
um so he asks uh to ask you what are the
most shockingly passionate this is in
Eric's language what are the most
shockingly passionate mathematical
structures and he gave a list of four
for him but he said he really wanted
your list okay let me say that
shockingly passionate mathematical
structures and shocking
okay is there something you can uh is
there something that jumps to mind sure
I'm here to shock yeah yeah so first of
all Eric Weinstein is a is a very dear
friend I have to say and I really really
appreciate and love him uh he's just
like my brother so you know it's it's
interesting to um
don't have a question posed by him maybe
if we can linger for a moment what do
you think is special about Eric
Weinstein for you know of his work and
his mind
the way he sort of straddles so many
different disciplines it's like a
renaissance man there are very few
people like that at any given moment let
alone the 21st century where information
has become so
you know huge that it's almost
physically impossible to be able to keep
track of things and yet he does and he
has his own unique vision and unique
point of view and he has integrity
which is like almost impossible like I
can't think of
I met so many people who possess that
those qualities almost no one
and also the ability
in some sense to um to embody the
balance that you talked about
of both the rigor of mathematics and the
uh the imagination Humanity also I would
say you know like we talk about
imagination
um as a kind of a Counterpoint to
knowledge or logic but just basic
Humanity you know just be basic just
compassion just being able to
because
um
every destructive I would say like every
destructive
um Society you know like be it Germany
you know and Hitler or Soviet Union
understand and so on
was based on some kind of uh what was
considered unassailable truth so a kind
of conceptual system you know if you
think about it right there is a
beautiful episode of this
um series by
um Jacob bronowsky you know
um where he talks about he filmed it in
Auschwitz
talking about the certainty that what
led the Nazis is a tool
killing people
wholesale was a certain it was almost a
mathematical idea
and they just basically bought into this
idea and checked out their Humanity at
the door
so I would say that antidote to this
type of thing is not necessarily even
imagination in a kind of elevated sense
that we have been discussing today that
is exemplified by by our greatest
scientists
and philosophers but just basic Humanity
you know basic human basic common sense
of just like knowing that it's just not
right and I don't care what my see what
my ideology tells me but I'm just not
going to do it so
that I think is kind of missing a little
bit in today's society because people
get a lot too caught up in in the
ideology in in certain conceptual
Frameworks so societies that lose that
basic human compassion the basic
Humanity around the trouble
oh very much so but not only Society
like a human being and Eric is one of
the people I agree with you
keeps that flame of you like I trust
that he will not do something
that's not human that's not right
I just feel that you know like there's
some some people you just kind of feel
that they won't cross that line yeah and
that's a huge thing you know today
because I have to say looking back
definitely
I have not heard people personally but
like I could be mean for instance I
could be harsh
and now I see it as a sign of weakness
as a sign of insecurity
you know I saw I saw your interview with
Rick Roswell the other day
it's beautiful I was really moved by it
but you know that at some point I was
like
I I looked at him at this sort of like
Dr Evil
kind of ashamed of it now but like you
know I'm kind of coming clean
and I would you know
because well why because I needed an
adverse adversary in my mind because I
projected onto him kind of the fears
that I had that we will be the AI Will
Conquer us and so on
and this was rooted in my
kind of Awakening moment in sense so
kind of a moment where I suddenly
started to see the other side
so but I wasn't sure yet
you see you have to feel it so I had to
have a fight about it yeah you had to
actually have the project I had to that
so it was not I believe that it was not
in me already so I had to throw it onto
somebody yeah
and that's not balanced yet so balance
is when you recognize that it's you
actually so and I had this moment
actually it was so amazing like I would
give this mean I would talk about Ai and
the dangers and he would always be my
like um foil you know I would put a
Sinister photograph of you okay on the
slide and it's like look at this guy he
wants to put Nano balls into your brain
and he's also like high-end High a top
executive at Google and so on like so I
would create this whole narrative
and then something happened
uh where I was giving a lecture this is
2015 at the in in Aspen Aspen ideas
Festival which is a wonderful Festival
so keynote speech actually and I and I
was doing my my usual stick and then
suddenly I said
I came up to that uh under the big
screen and there was a picture of him
there and I came up to the screen and I
kind of touched it with my hand and I
said but
I don't want to pick on Mr casual
because he's me I had this Revelation
that I'm actually fighting with myself
with my own fears
and and then I learned about
his
um his um his father that his father
died when he was young
and that he's in fact he's very
um discredited he's very um sincere an
upfront about it self-disclosure I think
it's very Essential by the way in all
this discussion like what really
motivates you
he said that he said it publicly many
times even as early as 2015 I could find
this information
that he wanted to reunite with his
father in the cloud and suddenly I saw
him not as a gray carcature
that exemplified all my fears
but as a human being
who a child longing for his father
grieving for his father
so suddenly it became a story a love
story
and you know
so that is so in other words I've seen
it in myself
this
capacity to
project my own fears and then fight with
other people over something that
actually was my own
and as soon as I got to this point of
seeing him and then my next lecture
actually I talked about it about him in
this way
and I and I said look you know it's a
love story and he is actually
um
and it's not how I would want to reunite
with my father uh
but like you said you know that if I am
consistent I have to allow the
possibility that different people
um
perceive things differently and so for
him
that's his imagination so you know how
who is this well Voltaire I think is
ascribed to Voltaire it's like I
disagree with you but I will fight to
death for you to have the right to say
it so now that I I feel like my position
is more like I disagree with him that
this is the way to
to approach death and to approach the
death of loved our loved ones and how we
miss them and how we
you know that sense of loneliness and
inability to interact directly
that
that's not something that is nice with
me
but I think it's also
it can also be called imagination from
his perspective and look motivated by
that
how much he has brought how many
interesting inventions like his musical
for instance naturally because his
father was a composer a music composer
and a conductor
so in other words from in the bigger
scheme of things
even if I think he's misguided
still I can't deny that it's a certain
leap of faith from his perspective to
try to say that this is the way we can
all connect to our loved ones and
because it is sincere and I see it now
sincere and in fact in your interview
you really teased it out of human it was
I was really moved by it I have to say
it's like he has mailed a little bit too
I said you know it was really really
sweet when he talked about his father
and I can relate you know my father died
four years ago and I can relate what a
heartbreak I was much older than Rey was
when his father died but I can relate to
this um to this longing and that grief
you know and when he is somebody sincere
and he puts his
opens his cards and you know
and say this is why that's what I want
to do it because I want to recreate my
father and I want to be able to talk to
him this way
then we have a series and then we
understand you know the opposite of it
would be not risk closing
and just
um
pretending that this is how it's
supposed to be in a scientific term so
it was replacing your real emotion but
come from the Heart by some kind of a
theory which comes from the mind and
this is where we can go astray because
then we get become captives of
Frameworks and conceptual systems which
may not be beneficial to our society in
tough times we need the people that have
not lost their way in the ideologies we
need the people who are still in touch
with their heart and you you mentioned
this with Eric is certainly true I
disagree with them on a lot of stuff but
I feel like when the world is burning
down Eric is one of the people that's
you can still count on to have a heart
I've talked a lot over the past year
about the war in Ukraine and the
possibility of nuclear war and it feels
like he's one of the people I would call
First
um
if uh if God forbid something like a
nuclear war will begin because you you
look for people with a heart no matter
their ideas that's right it takes
courage and it takes a certain
self-awareness I would say
and which brings I mean you know I think
the crucial is that that which was
inscribed you know on the Temple of a
Poland Delphia there was a statement
know thyself know yourself you know the
who am I ultimately it goes down to this
and all these debates and the point is
that it's like I used to be like I said
you know pessimistic at some point and I
was scared even of where development of
AI was going this is about 2014 2015.
and now I'm much more
so for instance after I saw Ray
courtswell as a human being after I
could relate to him
and sympathize
with him suddenly
I I stopped seeing him in the news like
before that I would always see him in
the news saying we're going to put
Nanobots in your brain by the year 2030
whatever you know and then we upload you
to the 20 by the 21st and I will be like
no you know the story was terrible
suddenly I didn't see him anymore
I had to you know so now it makes me
question who was creating the trouble
what was all with it was it him who's
creating stirring the trouble or was it
my mind you see and so as I become as I
became self-aware
suddenly other possibilities opened and
suddenly that conflict which by the way
if I kept giving this
nasty you know talks about him one one
day I suppose we'll have a debate and so
you have this
um one person says this and then yeah
and what I learned is that it never it's
a never-ending con this conflict just
does not end
but there is an alternative there is a
better way
which is to realize that it is you
arguing with yourself
now if you want to continue arguing with
yourself
continue as long as you need
just be careful not to destroy too many
things you know in the process but there
is an option of actually dropping it of
actually dropping it this is so I was so
surprised by this
yeah it's discovering in yourself the
capacity the human capacity for
compassion and you understand that
he has a perspective he is operating in
the space of imagination a human being
like you and we're all in this kind of
together
ultimately and also it's like with
realizing how much
I have screwed up you know comes with
humility also yeah so like I find it
extremely hard now to like really Lush
out at somebody and to say like you're
horrible whatever because immediately
question is
who am I to criticize you know so is
there another way to have a dialogue is
there a way to you know speaking you
know since we talked about
um the innocence of a child and how much
it drives a discovery in science and so
on you know I remember it was I think I
heard the Ashanti who gave this nice
example he's like when you're a kid you
know you go and you you play with your
friends and then you fight with another
kid and he was like I hate you I don't
want to see you again I just go home
like after half an hour okay what are
you gonna do you want to play so you
come out it's like hey you want to play
you don't talk about what happened you
don't rehash this you know
let's keep going and sometimes I think
we are on the verge maybe of learning
that
because I think that if we are can if we
continue to push
each of us our set of ideas and like
ideologies and like
you know what matters to us and so on
like yeah no no what matters to you but
like there are other ways to approach
other people there are other ways you
can find point of contact
speaking of which mathematics
mathematical formulas
are Universal represent Universal
knowledge two plus two is four whether
you vote for this guy or that guy in the
election you know how about that as a
point of of contact of commonality you
know and nobody can patent those
formulas did you know that there is a
Supreme Court decision that mathematical
formulas cannot be patented like
Einstein could not patent equal E equals
m c squared
it doesn't belong to him because if the
formal is correct
then it belongs to everyone
so what do you think of that all too
tricky question and if you want I can
deeply bias your answer by giving the
list of four that Eric provided oh no
let me give my mind I cannot see by the
way with you yes so but I can guess some
of them
so I'm going to try to do something
different from him so I already
mentioned one which is that you have one
dimensional
um in the medical system which is real
numbers you have two-dimensional which
is complex numbers you have four
dimensional and it's kind of it's
probably connected to what he wrote
Because has to do with some homotopic
groups of spheres and stuff like that
then of course one I love okay one plus
two plus three plus four plus five plus
six and so on
does it make any sense the sum I mean
you probably heard about this one it
became a very popular at some point one
plus two plus three I did I did a video
of a number file the the YouTube channel
about it maybe 10 years ago so one plus
two plus three plus four plus five
ostensibly
uh diverges goes to Infinity because you
got a bigger and bigger number and yet
there is a way to make sense of it
in which it it comes up to minus one
over twelve
how fascinating first of all the answer
is not even a positive number and it's
not an integer it's not a whole number
it's minus one over twelve so sometimes
people ask me what is your favorite
number
and it's a kind of a joke I say minus
one over twelve
it's actually 42.
so your favorite number is not an
ordered set
uh right so what else what else uh so
placements program of course I have to
mention that and we'll we'll explore
that in depth do you want do you want to
know what Eric said sure sphere aversion
boys surface hop vibration vibration
okay and
Pi 1 of SO3 okay oh yes so that's the
that's the famous cup trick you know
okay look so this is how it works
no tricks no tricks no matter what
honest it is magical okay
not because I'm tricking you so you
start with a a bottle like this or a cup
and you start twisting it at the same
time you twist your your arm then you
come so this is actually going to
um rotate it 360 Degrees the full turn
then you say okay I won't be able to do
another turn because then my arm would
really get twisted I'll have to go see a
doctor yet if I do it second time it
untwists
this is the pi one of SO3 Eric was
talking about it yes so there is
something where
the first motion is not trivial but if
you double down on it you come back to
the initial position
it's a very closely connected to the
fact that we have Elementary particles
of two types bosons and fermions
so bosons are for example photons or
carriers of other forces or the Higgs
boson it is called a boson for a reason
because it is a Boson uh in in honor of
Indian mathematician Bose b-o-s-e and
Einstein so this particles obey what's
called both Einstein statistics but then
there are other particles called
fermions
in honor of Enrico Fermi Italian porn
mathematician who worked in in the U.S
and and they follow what's called Iraq
Fermi statistics and those are electrons
and constituents of matter electrons
protons neutrons and so on and they have
a certain duplicity if you will and that
duplicity is rooted mathematically in
this in this experiment this little
experiment that they have just done
so I can I imagine speaking of
imagination okay yeah so I'm just kind
of briefing on this imagine a world in
which this will not be shocking or like
in this case it's not even shocking
because I haven't really explained the
details because I can't do it in two
minutes I I indicated
what this is all about and so on
but imagine a world in which this is not
foreign to most people that most people
have seen it before or they're not
afraid to approach this type of
questions because you know we talked a
little bit about Mass education but I
really believe that a lot of people in
our society and it is not not only in
the United States but throughout the
world a lot of people have been
traumatized
it's really PTSD that's why people when
they see might make a formula or like
even like how can they need to calculate
tip on the bill they it's just they're
terrified because it brings up those
memories when they were kids and being
called to Blackboard
and
solve the problem you can't solve a
problem and as groupless teacher says
you're an idiot sit down and you feel
ashamed and and then lowly and that
stays with you and so I think that
unfortunately that's where we are
dream and so my dream is that one day
we'll be able to overcome this
and actually all of these Treasures of
mathematics
will become widely widely available or
at least people will know where to find
them
and they will not be afraid of going
there and looking and I think this will
help because like I said for one thing
it gives you a sense of belonging it
gives you it kind of is an antidote the
kind of alienation and separation that
we feel today oftentimes because of
ideological divide
sectarian strife and all kinds of things
like that because then you will once you
see there's a critical mass of this
beauty
that kind of like tones on you is like
my God this is what we all have in
common
you mentioned language program we have
to talk about it sure at the core of
your book and your work is the language
program can you describe what it is
sure so
blank lens is a mathematician it's a
name of a mathematician Robert langlands
canadian-born
still alive he is was a professor at The
Institute for advanced study that we
talked about where Einstein and gildel
and other great scientists have worked
in fact he used to occupy the office of
Albert Einstein at The Institute for
advanced Stadium
so here uh
in in the late 60s
he came up with a set of ideas which
captivated a lot of mathematicians
several generations of mathematicians by
now
which came to be known as the language
program
and what it is about is connecting
different fields of mathematics which
seem to be far away from each other
for example number Theory which as the
name suggests deals with numbers
and various equations
with you know like x squared plus y
squared equals one
um and on the other side
harmonic analysis
something that
any music lover can appreciate because
uh the sound of a symphony can be kind
of decomposed into sounds of different
instruments and each of those sounds can
be represented by a wave like this like
a sine function
those are the harmonics they actually
the period of a harmonic periods of
different nodes are different they
correspond to different notes and
different instruments different
semitones if you will
but they all combine together into
something
diff something special which which is
not cannot be reduced to any one of
those so it's the mathematically it's
the idea that you can decompose a signal
into as a collection as a simultaneous
oscillation of several Elementary
signals
that's called harmonic analysis
so what language found is that some
really difficult questions
in number Theory can be translated into
much more easily tractable questions in
harmonic analysis that was his initial
idea but what happened next surprised
everybody that the kind of patterns that
he was able to observe the kind of
regularities that he was able to observe
which were quite surprising
were subsequently found in other areas
of mathematics
for example in geometry
and eventually in quantum physics
so in fact
Ed Witten who is a kind of a dean of
modern theoretical physicists the
professor at The Institute for advanced
study as well
got interested in this subject I
described in my book how it happened
and he was one instrumental in um
in Bridging the Gap between this
patterns in found in physics and in
Geometry finding kind of a
substrate a kind of a super stratum if
you will it's kind of uh over our kind
of a way to connect these two things
kind of a bridge between these two
Fields so I subsequently collaborate
with whiten on this and this has been
one of the major themes of my research
um it's sort of
I always found it interesting
to connect things to unite things
when I was younger I couldn't I couldn't
understand why
but I was always interested in
when when not in working in specific
field
by kind of but kind of cutting across
fields
and um
and then I we discovered that for
instance I took some people who know
what happens in this field but
don't know what happens in their field
and or conversely and then I would I
would like find it
imperative
to go out and explain to them to the
different sides what this is all about
so that more people are aware of this
hidden structure so this hidden
parallels if you will
so that has been sort of a theme in my
research and so I guess you know now I
kind of understand more why it's kind of
a violence you know like what we talked
about earlier
so can you
elucidate a little bit how what are the
mathematical tools that allow you to
connect these uh different continents of
mathematics
right is there something you can convert
into words that language was able to
find find and you were able to explore
further
I would say what it suggests is that
there is some and a hidden principles
which we still don't understand my my
view is that we still don't know why
that we can prove some instances of this
uh correspondences and connections
but we still don't know the real
underlying reasons which means that
there is a newly there is a certain
layer
beneath the surface that we see now
it is like the so the way I see it now
is like this
that there is something
three-dimensional like this bottle but
what we are seeing is this projection
onto the table and projection to wall
and then we can map things from one
projection to another and say oh my God
that's incredible
but the real explanation is that both of
them are projections of the same thing
and that we haven't found yet but that's
what I want to find so that's what
motivates me I would say
from number Theory to Geometry to
quantum physics so there is this one
thing which has different projections
except it's not just a table and the
wall but they're like many different
walls if you will
so what is the philosophical implication
that there is commonalities like that
across these very desperate fields
it means that what we believe are the
fundamental elements of
uh of mathematics are not fundamental
there is something Beyond it's like we
previously thought that atoms were
indivisible
then we found out that there is nucleus
and electrons and the nucleus consist of
protons and neutrons then we thought
okay protons and neutrons must be
Elementary
now we know they consist of quarks
so it's about kind of finding the quarks
of mathematics
of course beyond that there's maybe even
more which was my initial motivation to
study mathematics by the way right so
quarks was the first time you fell in
love with understanding the nature of
reality yeah
what was it like working with Ed Whitton
who uh many people say is one of the
smartest
humans in history
or at least mathematical physicists in
history
yes fascinating I enjoy I enjoyed it
very much I also felt they have to keep
up you know and uh so we wrote this long
paper and in 2007 and we collaborated
for about a year
I have known him before and we talked
before and we have seen him since and we
talked but it's very different to just
meet somebody at conferences and have a
conversation
as opposed to actually working on the
project together
so he's very very very very serious very
focused this is one thing which I have
to say I was really struck by this why
is he considered to be
such a powerful intellect by many other
powerful intellects
he had uh he has had this unique vision
of the subject
he was able to connect different things
especially
find connections between quantum physics
and Mathematics
almost unparalleled I I don't think
anyone comes close in some sense in the
last
uh you know 50 years to him in terms of
finding just consistently time after
time breaking around new ground new
ground so it it would basically one way
one could describe it is
he would take some idea in physics
and and then
find an interpretation of it in
mathematics
and then say distill it present it in
mathematical terms and tell
mathematicians this should be like that
you know kind of like one plus two plus
three plus four is minus 1 over 12.
I might think she'd be like no way
and then
it would pan out and mathematicians
would then like like a whole industry
would be created of
groups of mathematicians trying to prove
his conjectures and his his ideas and he
would always be proven right you know so
in other words being able to glean some
mathematical truths from
um physical theories that's one side on
the other hand
conversely applying sophisticated
mathematics he's probably
uh
the physics who kind of could learn
mathematics the fastest I don't think
some younger faces maybe could come
close but it's still quite for them a
long way to go to to get you know to be
comparable to whiten
to take some of the most sophisticated
mathematics
not learn it to the point where it
becomes a practitioner of the subject
practically
and then use it to gain some new
insights on the physics side
now of course the thing is that the
theory is that physics one could say is
an assault of a crisis in some sense
because of a current gap between the
sophisticated
theories which came from applying
sophisticated mathematics and the actual
universe
so we have theories first which describe
10-dimensional worlds 10 dimensional
space-time coming from string theory and
things like that
but we don't know yet how to
apply it to understanding our universe
a lot of progress has been made but it's
kind of a a kind of impasse right now
and at the same time the our most
realistic theories most advanced
theories of the four-dimensional
universe are in contradiction with each
other
the standard model describing the
three four known forces of nature the
electromagnetic strong and weak
to with great accuracy and Einstein's
relativity which describes the fourth
called gravity
everybody
above a certain age knows that one
these two theories are in contradiction
at the moment and string theory was one
of the the promise of string theory was
that it would unify those two and so far
it has not has not happened so we are
kind of at a very interesting place
right now and I think that new ideas
perhaps are needed and I I wouldn't be
surprised if Wheaton is one of those
people who come up with those ideas well
he has been one of the
one of the people that added a lot of
ideas under the flag of string theory
uh what do you think about this Theory
what do you think is beautiful about it
string theory
well first of all kind of
um you remember we talked about
pythagoreans and how for pythagoreans
the whole world was the symphony where
you have this different vibrations of
all the humans every human is a
vibration every every animal you know
every being every tree and every
Celestial body and so on
so strings that is kind of like that
because in string theory there is this
fundamental object which is a vibrating
string
and all particles are in a sense
supposed to be different modulations or
vibrations of that string so that by
itself is already interesting that you
kind of
describe this diversity of various
particles and interactions between them
using one guiding principle in some
sense
but also just the mathematical things
that come out of it the uh the kind of
um it looks impossible to satisfy
various constraints and then that is
sort of like a unique way to do it so
that's sort of the
every time that happens when you know
you have some system over like over
determined system let's suppose
you have to do like five interviews in
one day yeah and you wake up in the
morning and you're like that's
impossible
because then so many things have to
align for instance let's suppose you
have to go from one place to another so
then you have a commute and then who
knows maybe there is a traffic jam and
stuff like that and now suppose that it
all works seamlessly and there were like
a bunch of places where it could have
gone hopelessly wrong and it didn't and
then in the evening you're like wow it
worked that's beautiful right that's
kind of like
great luck you know we would save but
in science this happens sometimes that
you have this Theory which not supposed
to work because there's so many
seemingly contradictory demands on it
and yet there is a sweet spot where they
balance each other so string theory is
kind of like this
the unfortunate aspect of it is that it
balances itself in 10 dimensions and not
in four
so maybe there is another Universe
somewhere
[Laughter]
as a mathematician
for me all spaces are created equal yeah
10 dimensional four-dimensional so
mathematicians love String Theory
because it has given us so much so much
food for thought
but do you think
it's a correct
or a incorrect theory for understanding
this reality
so it might be a theory that explains
some 10th dimensional reality in some
other universe but is it potentially
what do you think are the odds again
Financial advice if you were to bet
what do you think are the odds that um
it gets us closer to understanding this
reality
well in the Forum that it is now that
seems unlikely but it could well be that
based on these ideas with some
modifications with some essential new
elements
it could it could work out so I would
say right now it doesn't look so good
like from the point of view that we of
what we from what we know
but maybe somebody will come in into a
juice like square root of negative one I
mean they already introduced but I mean
kind of like as a metaphor yeah maybe
somebody will come and say what if we do
this it looks crazy you know speaking of
news boor
he had this famous quote that he said to
somebody
there is no doubt that your theory is
crazy the question is whether it's crazy
enough to describe reality so that's
where we are kind of you know speaking
of crazy and crazy enough uh let me ask
for um
for therapy for advice for wisdom in uh
returning to Eric Weinstein and maybe
give some guidance to understanding
his view on his attempt at a theory of
everything that he calls geometric Unity
that he told me that you may have some
inkling of an under understanding of
if you were to describe this Theory to
aliens that visited Earth
how would you do it or you could try if
it was just me
visiting Earth uh how would you describe
your best understanding of it
he shared with me some of it when I was
in New York at Colombia like 11 years
ago we actually spent a lot of time
where he explained to me and I found it
beautiful
it has a very um original idea at the
core of it where you have this instead
of four dimensional instead of 10
dimensional he has 14 dimensional space
and I thought it was it was really
original and this is exactly
goes to the point I made earlier that we
need new ideas
I feel that without some fundamentally
new idea we won't be able to get closer
to understanding our universe now I have
a problem with the whole idea of Theory
of Everything You know I don't believe
that one exists nor nor that we should
um
aim to construct one
and I think it's it's really um not to
offend anybody but it's ultimately a
fault of education system of physicists
like in mathematics we do not we're not
brought up we're not educated as
mathematicians with the idea that one
day we will come up with the theory of
everything even though as a joke I said
that language program is mathematical
Theory of Everything
but I mean this is a kind of a
tongue-in-cheek but isn't a little bit
kind of that it's not really because
first of all it doesn't cover all fields
of mathematics and it covers specific
phenomena but isn't it spiritually
striving towards the same platonic form
of the theory of everything like
connecting connecting connecting but
connecting doesn't mean that it covers
everything right so you could connect
two things and then you have a
infinitely many other things which are
outside of the purview of this
connection
that's how it is in mathematics I I feel
and I would venture to say that most
mathematicians look at it this way like
there's no idea that somehow I think
it's actually impossible because we're
not talking about such a thing as like
one Universe we're talking about all
possible universes of all possible
dimensions and so on it is just not
feasible to have a unified unify
everything in one equation
now physicists on the other hand have
been brought up educated for decades
with this idea and to me and I I'm not
sure I should say that but I feel like
it's a kind of an ultimate ego trip
so that I have come up with the unified
I have found the intensity of everything
it's me and my name will be on it I
think a lot of physicists get educated
this way especially men take it
seriously yeah and I've seen that happen
and I think it is counterproductive I
think that a lot of people agree that
this debate is kind of I feel like it's
kind of settled I think I hear it less
and less
but
I disagree with the whole premise so you
uh it's interesting because because both
are interesting points you made which is
you don't think a Theory of Everything
exists and
you don't think the pursuit of a theory
of everything is good so I think you
spoke to the second thing which is
basically uh that the pursuit of a
theory of everything becomes like a drug
to the human ego that's right so it is a
huge motivating factor I don't deny that
but I feel that it's there are better
ways to motivate people than like that
then this way okay so
um I would say for instance if one
because then it's not a game of Winner
Takes to all in some sense
and In fairness when physicists say
Theory of Everything well Grand unified
theory they mean something very specific
which is unifying the standard model and
Einstein's relativity Theory which is a
theory of gravity
so they don't necessarily a cloud of
physics may say this worse but they
don't really mean them
I think it's important to realize that
that in my opinion that's not productive
and it's not visible anyway so having
said that there are some theories are
better than others obviously so for
instance Eric's theory has as far as I
understand does have a certain way of
producing some of the elementary
particles that we see and as well as the
force of gravity so it does have that
promise
I feel that from at least from the place
where I had seen it about 10 years ago
it still required a lot of work to get
to the point of actually saying that it
does work because
you know a lot there are a lot of
elements it's a it's a huge Enterprise
to have a theory because you have just
to describe the fields sort of the the
building blocks of the theory it's
already tremendous undertaking and he's
trying to do it for curved spaces and
greater generality which is what makes
it so unique and so beautiful
but then there are on top of that there
are this issue of quantization of
actually describing them as Quantum
field Theory and the quantum field
Theory even as a language as a framework
is currently incomplete in my opinion
and not only my opinion it's like
everybody's uh it's uh everybody agrees
on that that it's a it's a
it's a collection of Tricks so it's a
collection of tools it's a toolbox but
it is not uh a a
consistent rigorous Theory like number
theory in mathematics physicist has
still have still been able to derive
predictions
uh from it by and um confirm them with
to Great accuracy but the underpinnings
that it doesn't have the real grigorous
Foundation from mathematical perspective
so in that sense even if
in that framework a new Theory
could
um lead to an explanation of some some
new explanation of some phenomena it
would still be incomplete in a sense
because it wouldn't be mathematically
rigorous issue what I mean because the
whole framework is not yet on a firm
foundation
so it's not consistent right why is it
that the Universe should have
so that's to your first point do you
think the universe has a beautiful clean
when you show up and meet God and
there's one equation on the board and
the two of you just chuckle the things
that the equation exists
yeah there are such equations for
instance
let's say I am
interested in particular question right
so
in the language program say so moving
away from physics so let's talk about
math so
in in the context of language program
I have recently developed with my
co-authors I think of in cash then and
kind of a new strand a new flavor of the
language program if you will
but so far it's a sort of it's a vision
it's a set of conjectures
which we have proved in some cases but
not in full generality
so yes I would like to to use your
framework for meet the Creator and ask
her
what is the explanation of this and it
may well be that you will answer in a
way that I will just burst out laughing
it's like how could we not see it you
see so that I totally see
but I don't see one equation governing
one one equation governing them all
not one equation to govern them all but
it does seem that such equations exist
what she will tell you something and you
look back and say how could I not see it
it seems like the the truth at the end
of the day is simple
that we're seeking especially through
mathematics it seems somehow simple
the the the nature reality the thing
that governs it seems to be simple I
wonder why that is
and I also wonder if it's not totally
Incorrect and we're just craving the
simplicity
and then
mixing into the whole conversation about
how much The Observer that creates
Simplicity is part of the answer
it's a whole big giant mess
or a whole a whole big beautiful
painting
or Symphony you said of Eric uh
Weinstein that I find it remarkable that
Eric was able to come up with such
beautiful and original ideas even though
he has been out of Academia for so long
yes doing wonderful things in other
areas such as economics and finance I'd
like to use that kind of quote as just a
question to you about different places
where
um people of your level can operate so
inside Academia and outside what is the
difference
um of doing mathematics inside Academia
and outside
just not even mathematics but developing
beautiful original ideas
where's the place
that your imagination can flourish most
so the the limitations of academias
there's a community of people that
take a set of axioms
as gospel so it's harder to take that
leap into the unknown but it's also the
nice thing about Academia is some of the
most brilliant people in the world are
there it's that Community both the
competition the collaboration is there
um
yeah
I wonder if there's something you could
say sort of to uh
uh further about this world that people
that might not be familiar with
but I think you you gave a very good
description I'm not sure I could on it
because I don't have an overarching
theory of academic Academia yes I
definitely have been part of it and I'm
grateful because it is uh it gives you a
great sense of security
which comes with its own downside too
because you kind of like get a little
disconnected from The Real World because
you get tenure so you feel financially
secure you know I didn't pay you that
much so to speak you know relatively
speaking and uh it's comfortable but
it's not that much but you you can't be
fired so there is something about this
which I definitely have benefit from it
you know and it does
um people are not even aware what it's
like to to live outside where you can
you where you don't have this type of
security on the other hand
that also means that we're lacking
certain skills that sort of real people
in the real world have developed out of
necessity to deal with that sort of
insecurity so it kind of always cuts
both ways you know it was one-handed
gives and with the other hand it takes
away and it's a very interesting setup
and also on the one hand we are all
supposed to be the truth Seekers and
but in reality of course it is a human
activity and it is a human community and
with all kinds of good bad and ugly
things that happen a lot of them under
the radar screen so to speak and so
but maybe there is something to it there
is definitely there are definitely
people who are upholding kind of the old
tradition definitely and that is
inspiring and I aspire to be you know
one of those do my best so whether this
is
um a system that will stay or should
stay I don't know I really don't know
that's really fast yeah it's it's
fascinating what uh especially with it
just to introduce the bit of AI poison
into the mix as that changes the nature
of Education perhaps as well uh what the
role of the university is in the next 10
20 50 100 years I wonder
uh I wonder and I wonder that you know
how do you make sense that Einstein was
working after attempting I believe to be
a university Professor
yeah as a patent clerk well but I have
to say to these days
um
the the science has become so much
faster it is really hard to do it being
outside now Eric is unique in this way
even though he did you know go to Great
uh undergraduate and graduate uh you
know School schools
but and then worked for a while in
Academia
um there are very few examples like this
this is yutang Zhang who proved an
important conjunction number theory
about 10 years ago and is now it's
understanding is a professor at UC Santa
Barbara he worked outside of Academia
and was able to make
tremendous Advance on his own
this case is exceedingly rare
in part because Academia is trying to
protect its dwarf and it's kind of it's
it's creating this sort of prohibitive
cost of of an outsider that is true but
there is also something about how much
how much concentration in mathematics I
don't think people who are not who are
not in the field understand what kind of
focus
and concentration
actually doing like mathematics at the
top level these days requires because
we're not talking about something that
is more or less good it is something
which is unassailable you know it's
finding
this treasure at the bottom of the ocean
you know without uh uh you know the
accoland you know without oxygen and
that's why you know it's it's not the
people go crazy sometimes you know but
there is a reason for that well let me
let me ask you about that sort of just
to linger on that the amount of
concentration required
um Cal Newport
wrote a book called Deep work he's a
theoretical computer scientist
um
he took quite seriously the the task of
allocating the hours in the day for that
kind of deep thinking and then the
mathematicians is theoretical computer
scientists on steroids so for your own
life and what you've observed
well let me ask the big question how to
think
how to think deeply
how to find the mental psychological
pragmatic space to really sit there and
think deeply
how do you do it in the moment you
remember where you really deeply thought
what was it an accident was it
deliberate
no it's deliberate because you know
um
first of all my first years
as a mathematician you know
I worked every day
and weekends holidays doesn't matter
um
I didn't even question that so I would
feel something's missing if I
took a day off
and you know
so it was just a kind of a sustained
effort the point is that still the
process is non-linear to go back to what
we discussed earlier that in other words
the way I see it is you just you are
making an effort to to bring all the
information into
Focus what you believe is correct and
you're playing with different
ways of connecting things
but it is a total Miracle when it when
suddenly there is inside strikes it is
not something that in my experience
could be predicted
or even
um anticipated you know or like brought
closer
there's a famous story about Einstein
that he used to you know go uh think
think and then go for a walk and like he
would whistle and sometimes so I
remember the first time I heard the
story
I thought how interesting so the
coincidence that he came up to him when
he was whistling but in fact it's not
this is how it works in some sense that
you have to prepare for it but then the
moment it happens when you stop thinking
actually so the moment of Discovery is
the moment when thinking stops and you
know you kind of you kind of almost
become that truth that you're seeking
but you cannot do it by Will in some
sense it's some it's kind of like you
know how in eastern tradition they have
this concept of Satori like in Buddhism
and Buddhism you have this Satori which
is enlightenment
and so the various reports of
Buddhist monks or Buddhist Masters who
have had experience Satori
but they say you can't
you can't uh do it by will you cannot
make it happen
if anything you have to relax to let it
come to you you know it's kind of like
that it's kind of like that so
I think that what matters
but you say how to think the point is
that we're talking about such an
esoteric area is really esoteric area
it's really strange subject where you
try to
to fit everything
in this very very stringent set of rules
those rules isn't it basically the the
pure the hardest manifestation of a
puzzle that we're all solving in
different other disciplines but this is
the the hardest puzzle yes and no
because there is just a different
for instance there is a different
Criterion for what constitutes progress
for instance physics
a lot of arguments they make they are
not rigors from mathematical perspective
it is kind of an intuitive argument we
think it is like this and this is
acceptable in the subject for a good
reason and on the so there is some play
it's more it's more like human activity
day-to-day activity like for instance if
you and I discuss something you have an
idea and I have an idea and we argue
about it and something seems more
plausible
something seems less plausible and so we
made decide to take this point of view
of that point of view as a provisional
sort of like
point of view and go with it in
mathematics it doesn't work this way you
either prove it or you don't
and oftentimes
you get to the point where there is this
much you need to prove and it just it
just wouldn't it wouldn't come to you
and you just don't see it and it can
have it can go on for months
super frustrating but without it it is
it is nothing kind of you know I would
love to hear your opinion uh to the
degree that you know it um of the proof
of her mouth's Last Theorem by Andrew
Wiles which seems to have this element
perhaps for years to the degree that you
know perhaps can you explain from
azler's theorem and what your thoughts
are in the process that Andrew Wells
took that seemed to at least for my sort
of romantic perspective seemed to be
very lonely yes
it's a lovely profession
and hopeless and and uh
and sort of the pro you put it really
nicely because it's it feels like
there's a lot of moments where you feel
like you're close you feel like 19 is
done yeah and there is this one stubborn
thing
which just does not compute you know
doesn't happen and you're trying to find
that push for this last link and it
could take and nobody knows how long
it's going to take would it be useful to
maybe try to explain from us Last
Theorem sure it's easy to do
it
empty missed I think I always think that
everything can be explained you know
even though I say that not everything
can be explained but in in mathematics
you know within this particular
framework I think that I always feel
optimistic when people ask me to explain
something I I always start with the
assumption that they will understand yes
you know
so
let's try
uh ferma's last ethereum one of the
jewels
sort of of mathematics of all time
a beautiful story also behind it Pierre
Verma a great French mathematician who
lived in the beginning of mostly worked
at the beginning of uh what 17th century
and uh he actually has to his credit a
number of important contributions but
the most famous is called firma's last
ethereum or repairman's great ethereum
and the reason why it became so famous
is in part because he actually claimed
to have proved it himself and he did it
on a margin of a of a book that he was
reading which was a actually important
book by diafantos about
equations with coefficients and whole
numbers
and he wrote on the margin literally
I this equation you know this problem
which I will explain in a moment
um I have solved it I have found a proof
but this margin is too small to contain
it
at some point I I give I was given a
public talk about this and I made it as
a joke I made a tweet in which I wrote
that I have proved this theorem but 280
characters are not enough and the kind
of customer admit sentence yeah so this
was 17th century Twitter style proof
okay but a lot of mathematicians took it
seriously because he had great
credibility he did made did make some
major contributions
and the search was on so for 350 years
about
350 years
um it remained
unproved with many people trying
and failing until in 1994
and that no in 1993 Andrew Wiles
announced a mathematician from Princeton
University announced the proof and it
was very exciting because he was one of
the top number theorists in the world
and unfortunately about a year later a
gap was found so that's exactly what we
were talking about earlier you have 99
of the proof this one little thing does
not quite connect and this nullifies the
whole thing even though well you could
say there's some interesting ideas but
it's not the same as actually having a
proof so he apparently was really
frustrated and he was really a lot of
people thought that it's going to be
another 100 years or whatever
and then luckily he was able to enlist
with with the help assistance with of
his a former student also great number
theorist Richard Taylor they were able
to do that one percent so to speak well
some people might say it maybe not one
but five percent or whatever but it
definitely was an important ingredient
but it was not he had a sort of like a
big new
set of ideas and this one thing didn't
pan out they were able to close it with
Taylor and in it finally was published
and I think was accepted and the
refereed in 95 and since it's believed
to be correct
now uh what he proved actually was not
verma's theorem itself
but a certain statement which is called
shimurtaniam away conjecture named after
three mathematicians to Japanese
mathematicians and one French porn
mathematician who works and also the
institute for advanced study in in in
Princeton
and it was my colleague at UC Berkeley
Ken ribbett who in the 80s connected the
two problems so this is how it often
Works in mathematics you want to prove
statement a
instead you prove that a is equivalent
to B
so after that if you can prove B this
would automatically imply that a is
correct this will happen here a waslas
theorem B was simultaneous conjecture
and that's what
Andrew Wiles and Richard Taylor really
proved so it requires to get to firma's
Last Theorem it requires that bridge
which was established by my colleague
Ken Ribbit at UC Burke so now what is
the statement of Herman's Last Theorem
um
let me start with Pythagoras since we
already talked about it let me start
with Pythagoras ethereum which describes
the right triangles so what is the right
triangle it's a triangle in which one of
the angles is 90 degrees like this so it
has three sides the longer side is
called hypotenuse
and then there's two other sides so if
we denote the high points the lengths of
hypotenuse by Z and the two other sides
X and Y
then Z squared is equal to x squared
plus y squared
so that's the equation or x squared plus
y squared equals z squared
and it turns out this equation
has Solutions in natural numbers
main is actually infinitely many
solutions in natural numbers
for example if x is you take x equals
three
y equals 4 and Z equals 5.
then they solve this equation because 3
3 squared is nine
4 squared is 16.
9 plus 16 25. and that's 5 squared
so x squared plus y squared equals z
squared is solved by x equals three y
equals four is equals five and there are
many other Solutions of that nature and
we should say the natural numbers are
whole numbers that are non-negative
that's right one two three four five six
and so on now what's verma's Last
Theorem Firma asked what about what will
happen if we replace squares by cubes
for example so X Cube plus y Cube equals
z Cube
are there any solutions in
what do you call natural numbers
it turns out there are none
what about fourth powers
again none well it seems like none right
so that was that was a statement so the
theorem says that the equation x cubed
plus y cubed equals e cubed has no
Solutions in natural numbers
uh remember natural means positive whole
numbers so of course there's a trivial
solution zero zero zero so that this
works but you need all of them to be
positive
x to the fourth plus y to the fourth
equals z to the fourth also has no
Solutions
uh x to the fifth plus y to the fifth
equals e to the fifth no Solutions so
you kind of see the trend
x to the N plus y to the N plus equals z
to the N if n is greater than two
has no Solutions in natural numbers that
is a statement of therma's last year
deceptively simple as far as famous
theorems are concerned you don't need to
know anything beyond standard
charismatic addition and multiplication
of natural numbers
that's why a lot of people
both
Specialists and amateurs
try to prove it so because it's so easy
so that is so easy to formulate
so in fact I think Therma proved the
case of Cubes I think he did actually
prove some elsewhere in the case of
Cubes but so it remained like four there
are infinitely many cases right you have
to even if you prove it for cubes and
for fourth power and fifth then still
there's six sevens and so on the
infinitely made cases in which it has to
be proved
and so you see
um the separated simple result took 350
years to prove
and you know but in a sense it's like
mathematicians you know you would think
mathematics is such as sterile
profession everybody's so serious you
know almost like we're all wearing like
lab coats and like take an elevator to
the to the every Tower and however look
at all this drama
look at all these dramas like we also
like drama we also have narratives we
also have our myths
here is the guy is the 16th century
mathematician or 17th century
mathematician who lives a note on the
margin and motivates others to find the
proof then how many cards were broken
that they believed that they found the
proof and then later it was realized
that the proof was incorrect and so on
and brings us to modern day and one last
attempt and reviles who is very serious
and respected and esteemed mathematician
announces the proof only to be faced
with the same reality of his hopes
dashed seemingly dashed and like there
is a mistake it doesn't work and then to
be able to recover a year later how much
drama in this one story it's amazing but
from what you understand for what you
know what was the process for him
that uh that is similar perhaps your own
life of of of walking along with the
problem for months
not years yes so he worked he has given
interviews about it afterwards so we
know that he described his process
that number one he did not want to tell
anybody
because he was afraid that people find
out that he's working on it
because he's was such a top level
mathematician
people would guess that he has some idea
that there is some idea so you know
if you just know that somebody's has an
idea this already gives you a great
boost of confidence right so he didn't
want people to have that information so
he didn't tell anybody that he was
working on it number one be lonely
number two he worked on it for seven
years if I remember correctly by himself
and
then then he he thought he had it and he
was elated obviously he was you know
very happy and he announced it at the
conference I think it was in Cambridge
University or Oxford University in the
UK in 1993 I believe
so
you know
this
is really interesting because all of us
we can really all weapons can relate to
this because I I remember very well my
first problem how I solved my first
problem
uh I described it in 11 math in my book
so
uh it was I was how old was I I was 18
years old I was a student in Moscow
and I was just I just lucked out that I
was introduced to this great
mathematician since I you know I was not
studying at Moscow University because of
anti-Semitism in the Soviet Union so I
was in this technical school but I was
lucky that I had a mathematician who
took me under his wing
and Dmitry Fox who actually
later came to the to the US and he's
still a professor at the UC Davis
not so far from from me
uh so he gave me this problem and
it was rather technical so I will not
try to describe it but I do remember how
much uh effort you know the that
excitement but also kind of a fear what
if I don't have what it takes you know I
lost sleep so this was one one
consequence of this
I for the first time in my life I had
trouble falling asleep and this actually
stayed for a couple years afterwards so
then it was kind of like a wake-up call
that I should be to take care of myself
not work too late and so on so that was
sort of like that experience and I was
lucky that I was able to find a solution
number one within two months Maybe
and it was very it was surprising and it
was beautiful like it the answer was was
in terms of some something which seemed
to be from A Different World from a
different area of mathematics
so it's very happy but I do remember
this more this moment when suddenly you
see that
it's like you in this case it was
literally I had to compile these
diagrams with what mathematicians call
homology groups and spectral sequences
and manually calculate some some numbers
and trying to discern some system in it
and suddenly I saw that how they all
were governed by this one one force so
to speak one pattern and that was
absolutely wow so it's like I mean what
was it so you're sitting there at a desk
actually you know I lived in a town
outside of Moscow so I used to take I
would take a train to Moscow so it's
what we call in Russia electric you know
like this electric train which was super
slow it took more than two hours to
cover that distance and I think that the
crucial Insight came when I was in this
and I just I was I had to contain myself
so I don't start screaming you know
because there were other passengers in
the car so I was sitting there and
staring at this paper so you know what I
remember that what came to me
I have something now
which nobody else in the world has I
have a proof of first of all I did not
it was not just the proof like in the
case of Irma the statement is already
made that's why it's called conjecture
you know you make a statement you don't
have a proof yet then you try to prove
it in my case I did not know what the
answer would be there was a type of
question where the answer was unknown so
I had to find the answer and prove it
and the answer was very nice so nobody
knew as far as I could tell nobody knew
because my teacher told me that he
explored all the literature and this was
not known so this was
suddenly I felt that I was in possession
of this
now it was a little thing it was not
cured for cancer you know it was not
a large language model you know but it
was something undeniably real meaningful
and it was mine kind of you know like I
had it nobody else I had not published
it I didn't even tell I hadn't even told
anybody and it is a very strange feeling
you know to have to have that were you
worried that this treasure could be
stolen
not at the time not at the time so later
on there were situations where I was
exposed to that those type of
experiences but at that time I didn't
think of that I was still this
starry-eyed kid you know who was just
obsessed with mathematics with his
Beauty and Discovery discovering those
beautiful facts beautiful results so I
didn't think about I didn't even think
that it could be possible that somebody
could steal it or whatever uh I just
wanted to share it with my teacher as
soon as possible you know and and he he
understood quickly and he's like yeah
good job you know
is there some something you can give
color to the drama Erica's talk Eric
Weinstein has spoken about some of the
challenges some of the triumphs and
challenges of his time at Harvard so
is there some something to that drama of
people stealing each other's ideas or
not allocating credit enough oh sure yes
um all of that and and creating
psychological stressors because of that
yes unfortunately on young minds and so
on could have a very bad effect is that
just the way of life or is this
um I think we can definitely do better
and I think the first step is to kind of
admit that we are not 100 Seekers of
truth that we are human beings and all
the
The Good and Bad and The Ugly
qualities
um can be present and to have some kind
of dialogue in my subject in mathematics
this has not happened yet there have
been some famous cases where people have
been accused which had been resolved or
partially resolved or unresolved
and uh everybody knows it but there
isn't a systematic effort as far as I
can tell of really trying to create some
rules some ethics rules this is this is
fair game this is not fair game so that
as a community we strive to get better
I think that for most people it's more
like keeping your head in the sand and
kind of pretending that it doesn't
happen or it happens some isolated
incidents well I don't my experience is
not like that at all I think it does
happen much more often than it should
that's my opinion uh so there's the pool
of Academia is fascinating one of the
reasons I really love it is you have
young minds with fresh ideas
and that that same innocence you had
with when you're first on the train have
that brilliant breakthrough and then you
throw that in together with senior
exceptional world-class scientists who
have first of all are getting older
um second of all maybe they have
partaken in the drug of Fame and money
and status and recognition so that
starts to a little bit corrupt all of
our human minds and you throw that mix
in together yeah
mostly without rules
and uh is beautiful because that's where
the ideas of old
contend with the the new wild-eyed crazy
ideas and they clash and there's a
tension and it's there's a dance to it
but then there's the old human
corruption that can take advantage of
the young minds
it's unclear what to do with that
I mean part of that is just the way of
life and the strategies
um and oftentimes when you look at who
wins the Nobel Prize it's also tragic
because sometimes so many
minds are like the trajectory to the
Breakthrough idea involves so many
different Minds young and old yeah I
mean
you're right it's I think it's like
every and there was everything else the
the through the the path is to more
self-awareness and it's like owning up
your own
stuff and uh not blaming other people
not projecting onto other people but
taking responsibility
and that's true for everything and
the problem here unique problem for
mathematics I would say physicists and
chemists are better they have they
actually have better sort of ethical
rules and so on special biologists like
because I think in part it's because
there is much more money involved
because they have to get grants and so
on so for them the question of priority
who discovered what first is much more
serious because there's really some
serious money mathematics who cares you
know that Famous Last Theorem was proved
yeah did Andrew Wells become a
millionaire no I think they won the
prize but those prices are not I think
that one was a big price but uh but in
general there's not going to keep I
think he won the Apple price eventually
which is about a million dollars so but
you know I sometimes I joke about this
that this is the hardest way to win a
million dollars
so you know
but amongst mathematicians I think the
trouble is that we are so insulated
from a society because it's such a pure
subject it draws in very specific uh
psychological types and I can speak
about myself I did not realize it at the
time but later on I definitely saw I
mentioned some of it earlier that for me
mathemax was a refuge from the cruelty
of the life I experienced from
discrimination that I experienced when I
applied to Moscow University at 16 being
failed at the exam and stuff like that
which I described in my book as well but
um that was my way I was like I don't
trust this world I don't want to deal
with it
I want to hide in this platonic reality
of pure forms
this is where I know how to operate I
love this and and I couldn't be bothered
in some sense for a while it happened up
to a point as as I was getting older and
more mature I was becoming more and more
interested in other things
but I think that's one of the reasons
and one of them
reasons why I wrote Love and math
was precisely to break that cycle
that it's it's the quiet guy in the
corner that goes into math and not the
flamboyant you know a joke or like you
know DJ
I wanted to show
uh how beautiful this subject is to
attract this new blood so that different
psychological types and
more women
uh would join because then they would
have students who would look at them and
whom they will inspire and then it would
be a instead of a vicious circle it
would be a virtual Circle and I have to
say I think it's happening not because
of my efforts on alone obviously there
are many other messages who are around
the same time started to put more effort
because see if the old stereotype of
mathematician you're so enclosed you're
not interested in even exposing the
beauty of your subject to other people
you see and then it becomes this vicious
circle
but you know this one day you know I not
one day all the time I meet I meet these
students who say
your book is the reason why I chose math
as my major and I am proud especially
when it's women who tell me this and
they are cool they are DJs at the same
time and they are social and they have
friends and they go out and so on you
see so they are then they carry the
torch because then they will be more
likely
to
share this beauty with others to attract
more students and so on so I think this
this kind of this dumb was broken so now
you'll have more influx and once we have
people who are more can able to connect
at the personal level that's when we
also become more self-aware as a
community I think and that's when we
might be we should be able to have a
chance to improve in terms of our
ethical rules and stuff like that
so let me return to our friend Eric
Weinstein for a question that I would
ask anyway but let me let's have a
non-russian ask the Russian question
um
ask him about the Russian concepts of
friendship science gender and love
versus the American
you can um so there is a there is a deep
Romanticism that you have
that runs through your book love and
math
is is part of that's something you've
picked up from the Russian culture
what can you speak to that uh fueled
both your fascination with math and your
fascination no your um
your prioritization of The Human
Experience of Love hmm good question I
definitely there is some influence of
the Russian culture Russian literature
perhaps you know
but also you know like there's so many
things
um how do you how do we develop certain
sensibilities like why do we care about
this and not that like why do I care for
instance about like you said
about this romantic ideals so to speak
of mathematics that's certainly not
something that is automatic you know
some people care about it some people
don't and I'm not saying it is Superior
or inferior it's just how my composition
my psychological composition is like
that
and
it's an interesting question like what
is the cause of it so I think that
we cannot really know but there are some
aspects of it of course the experiences
life experiences are
um
upbringing family like I was you know I
was surrounded by Love by my parents on
the one hand but in the one on the other
side uh perhaps they were a little
overprotective of me so I was kind of
like
you know
um too much kind of like taking care of
so then when I
had it develop certain sensitivity but
it was kind of not ready for the
challenges the real world of the real
world so then that struggle and that and
then being lost
and then being able to overcome and to
learn and then if you do in Universe if
you don't lose you don't appreciate
maybe but sometimes when we lose
something and then regain it then we
cherish it we appreciate and then become
something important also uh various
um difficulties you know the upsetting
experiences or one could say traumatic
experiences
growing up you know in the Soviet Union
that was not uh awoken Park you know it
was there were a lot of issues there
um that I had to go through and
and then it doesn't break you make you
stronger but in my case
what happened was that you know
some for some of it it took me 30 years
to really come to terms with it and to
really understand what happened
he gave me this motivation
um to to strive to become a
mathematician which maybe I wouldn't
have otherwise it charged me
supercharged me I'm talking about for
instance the experience with exam
at Moscow University can you take me
through that experience so
this is 1984 we spoke about Orwell
earlier
and
I was applying to Moscow University
mathematics Department it's called
Muhammad which is like for people who
don't know like the place was the only
place to study pure mathematics in
Moscow period but also but also
interesting one of the great places on
Earth and it's like a huge building this
you know this monolith of a building of
Moscow University
so because as I said you know a year
earlier evgenie evgeny which converted
me into math capitalizing on my love for
physical quantum physics and so we I
spent a whole year studying with him and
I was already kind of at the level of
you know and some in some subjects a
level of like early graduate Graduate
Studies
so it seemed like it would be a breeze
to go to get into Moscow University
but in fact little did I know that uh
there was a
a policy of anti-Semitism where students
like me would be failed by special
examiners
mostly during the oral exam with
mathematics but
um
occasionally would be written tests and
stuff
now my father is Jewish
by Blood it was not religious his family
was not religious my mom is Russian
and but I was since my last name was my
father's name so it was very easy too
to read what my nationality was
and so there was this can you imagine
there were special people who would
screen up applicants who would put aside
the files of the undesirables there
would be special examiners who were
actually professors at this University
who would be designated as
those who would take the exam from those
undesirables it was it's almost comical
when you look back now and also like
questions why there was no reason other
than just hatred of the other that's how
I see it and just to give a little bit
more color so
uh because you mentioned nationality
it's a little uh Quark that perhaps
gives an inside to the bigger system
that the nationality listed on your
birth certificate when you're Jewish is
Jewish and when you're non-jewish is
this is Russian for me it was Russian so
first of all in this in the inner part
everybody has an internal passport
and there you have first name petronic
name
last name
date of birth so these are four and the
fifth colon
is nationality
which comes from the nationality of the
parents and so on in my case was written
Russian because my mom was Russian but
it didn't save me
because that was my dad's last name
and so
so anyway this was a a toughest
experience that I had a bunch up until
that point
and there was these two people who came
into the room where I was the only
undesirable all other kids were being
questioned by other examiners but they
told me that we could not uh question
you we're waiting for special examiners
so I was like oh
something is a food and so these two
guys came and it's for four hours
basically and were asking me questions
which were not in the program and so on
but you know I was a kid I was 16 years
old I tried to answer the best I can but
it was a setup
it's been documented since then there
are even lists of problems
that were given to undesirables in those
days in my year
um no no Jewish applicants as far as I
know Jewish by this metric
were accepted so then I had to go to
this um
there was one school technical school in
Moscow
which was the institute for oil and gas
exploration which had a Applied
Mathematics program
and that's where me and many of my many
of the kids who were not accepted to
Moscow University ended up
and so
but the point is so and then I was I was
so motivated by this because I wanted to
show those guys you know
that within five years less than five
years I got a letter from the president
of Harvard University
inviting me as a visiting Professor to
Harvard I was 21 I was barely 21 because
I already did some research in the
meantime that's how motivated I was you
know so but the interesting aspect of it
is that for for the longest time
afterwards I was telling myself a story
that nothing really happened
it wasn't so bad okay so I was failed
but I knew that I was going to succeed
it was 30 years later
that I finally
got to meet that boy that 16 year old
that I
that I neglected this time and I
realized that he died that it was a
crushing blow the Innocence not just
instance because there was no way it
looked like there was no way I could
become a mathematician because if I
don't if you don't accept me there
it's over
I didn't know that I could actually find
this striving applied math program and
then eventually somebody would take me
under his wing and so on and then could
move to the United States this was not
in the realm of possibilities
so in other words I could there was
nothing to look forward to
it was clear that it's over I cannot
I cannot do what I love
and so when I finally
when I finally connected to that boy oh
my God that was a totally different
experience all the pain and all the
trauma came to the surface and it was
a kind of a tsunami
I didn't I wasn't sure I would survive
this so it was so hard
and what happened was I was invited to
to give a talk about this in New York
it was kind of a spoken word event
uh about science but like personal
experiences related to science this was
almost a year after
my book came out
in my book
one of the first chapters is a chapter
about this experience
but what I realized now is that I wrote
it from the third person perspective
I knew the facts
but I was not emotionally connected to
that experience however
since I wanted to write the book and to
connect to my readers I allowed the boy
to write it
so a lot of people were touched by it
and they would people would say wow that
chapter you know it really got a lot of
resonance it was translated into other
language even before the book was
published
I was surprised by this because I didn't
know yet so the adult Edward was not yet
in touch but the book gave the outlet
to the child
so
and that kind of
started the process
so finally
um
almost a year later I'm in New York in
this
at this event and the night before
I'm in my hotel room and I was like okay
what am I going to talk about tomorrow
and I take a piece of paper it's just
you know my usual like preparation you
know for things and then suddenly I have
this Vision that I will walk up to the
microphone tomorrow and I will just
start crying
and
it's like
but by that time I already had an
Insight that it's possible to have that
kind of a splitting kind of dissociation
I was not but if things were happening
quickly there was someone in my life who
explained to me this idea that
some things are under the radar of
awareness but they may still influence
you
and a lot of that could be connected to
some experiences in your childhood so I
was kind of ready for it from different
angles but I was so surprised because I
was like what is there to remember I
know I know everything so then my inner
voice says all right then you have
nothing to worry about
so we'll go tomorrow
and you will speak about this and if you
start crying it's not a problem I was
like no I don't want to cry in front of
people
I want to find out what it is what
happened
and I sat on my bed closed my head
and it came
so
it's hard to describe so this is what
and the sheer energy of it and how much
effort it took to suppress it actually
for all these years how much effort it
took to build that
in Russian you know that that hardcore
you know around myself yeah so that and
the thing later I realized there were
moments when it could come out
and for instance I developed this fear
of public speaking and all kinds of
little things that I now feel were
connected so anyway I saw what happened
now Through The Eyes of that child I saw
how difficult it was how crushed he was
and it looked completely hopeless and I
felt like what's the point of living now
for me now that I know how cruel this
world is which I didn't realize before
because I prefer to wear this pink you
know the the rose Rose Colored Glasses
but then something happened it's so
strange
it's like you feel that inside of you
there is this dead child and it is
incredibly sad I mean it's like
I can't even describe it but suddenly he
comes alive and suddenly it's like
oh he's here and I and I got a little
talk with him and I said look you know I
know now and thank you I'm so sorry that
I neglected you for so long you know I
didn't know
thank you
for doing this and it's almost like you
know I felt like the image came to mind
is like a fallen soldier like you leave
a fallen soldier on the battlefield a
wounded soldier and then you come back
to take him with you
and
and I said but look look what we have
done look at us now it was not in vain
we are doing okay
and it's kind of almost just like
holding
holding holding that
child and that
that sense of who I am you know and
feeling it so
the next day
I went to the microphone and I let him
speak for the first time
about his experience in his own voice
it was incredible people were crying and
afterwards came up to me and started
sharing stories and so on because it is
a story it's a universal story it's
archetypal story
it's the story of rejection and
being treated unfairly
we all know it and I think it's so
important to realize that
it's so it's possible to revisit those
moments it's possible to reconnect to
our little ones it's possible to bring
them back
and we are better for it because this
changed my life this experience then
they were then suddenly it's like a
floodgates there were many other things
that came
that's when I became
interested in the dimensions of
imagination and intuition and so on
because suddenly I realized that I was
deprived of those of that possibility of
looking at the World Through The Eyes of
a child because that child was frozen in
time it was I was not connected to him
but suddenly he's with me and he's like
almost like opens his doors and says
look good look at this look at this
so
if I could ask you
about there's a difficult idea here
there's a tension I've interacted with a
few folks in my personal life and in
general that have lived through uh this
experience of unfairness and cruelty in
the world as young
people
and
what wisdom do you draw from
the the the the action you took of not
acknowledging that you're a victim to
Cruelty but instead just working your
ass off working harder
and then this the flip side of that is
you eventually reconnecting with the
cruelty that you experience because if
you did that early on I was not ready
for it it is a defense mechanism I could
be I could have come you know there were
kids who commit suicide after this
experience I could have commit suicide
because it's too much
and it is well known afterwards of
course I became aware of all the
literature about childhood trauma and so
on and I have been I've been speaking
publicly about it since then too and so
you know it is well-known issue and
well-known
um
kind of a universal phenomenon I think
that interesting enough
even though one now I see a lot of
discussion of it now that my eyes are
open but somehow before I didn't see it
so that which also shows you how our
confirmation bias kind of like how we
screen ourselves how we turn the Blind
Eye to things which do not confirm our
views or for which we are not yet ready
and by the way nobody should push to do
it too soon I'm glad I I developed
certain force a certain strengths
I was confident
um I was strong to withstand this and if
I weren't who knows how it could turn
out so it is a very subtle kind of
alchemical process
which I don't think there is a recipe
there's a formula
the reason I'm talking about this is
just to share this experience because I
think that the only thing we can do in
this in some sense is to share with each
other because then we can find
for instance if somebody
shared with me
it would naturally Lead Me Maybe to get
closer to that to kind of understanding
it's really just personal stories it's
not
obviously there is a there is a
component where professionals could be
involved professional therapists and so
on in my case it somehow happened
miraculously well I did have support but
not not from professional therapists but
from like dear friends
so I did I did have you didn't you do
need I had somebody at the time who
basically held my hand and through this
experience yes it was invaluable and it
could not be done otherwise
so I think it's very common and here's
the thing
I would not do it in any other way
when you when I reconnected
and I saw all the horrors and so on but
I also was able to see
that my examiners were victims
of Their Own
situation that they became they fell for
this bogus
series or maybe it was more of a issue
of career advancement or something and
I also realized they must have suffered
as well because they must have had some
kind of consciousness of conscience
about it that acting this way towards
sort of
basically kids you know
so it's not it wasn't pretty from their
point of view so I could forgive them
and I could like also appreciate what a
what a boost of energy it gave me yeah
if I was accepted and I was just where I
was a first-year student I lived I would
live in a dorm because I was in the you
know I'd be probably partying and
drinking and who knows what maybe I
wouldn't even become a mathematician
but this
focused me like a laser without me even
thinking about it it just happened I
just I couldn't do I didn't care about
anything but doing mathematics and it
paid off you know it changed my life so
was it good or bad
Paradox
seems like life is full of those
um you said you lost your father four
years ago yeah
what have you learned about life from
your dad that's another another big one
yeah because I was very close to him
and uh it was tough it was tough
and I was not
I was sort of not ready for it because
up until that point I lived pretending
that death does not exist
when my grandparents died I was already
in the U.S
so it's very convenient and I couldn't
go back so I grieved but it kind of was
a bit abstract for me I didn't see their
dead bodies you know I didn't
bury them and so on so I waited till so
my the first death in my life was my
father
like of a really close loved ones and I
was absolutely devastated
you know he was such an amazing creature
such an amazing human being he was the
kindest the smartest the most funny just
it's really funny and just really fun to
be with you know this is what I miss
obviously I mean I would just love to
hang out with him
so
and then suddenly it's not there
so it's tough but it kind of changed my
perspective you miss him
I miss him tremendously
I miss intermittently but I in a way I
learned that he never left me in some I
mean it sounds so words are so you know
like they are
they cannot express in words this what
I'm trying to say
but
um do you carry him
with you yeah and in some sense I always
did and and I
I
saw that that it's always been
um it was really we were one in some
sense you know like we were but there
was this experience of
two two people
being together and that I missed
tremendously
but he gave me so much and I you know
let me tell you one aspect of it for
instance
when he was a kid his father was sent to
Gulag on bogus pretenses right so he
when he was 16 he replied to University
he wanted to become a theoretical
physicist
by the way my love for trichophysics was
to the large extent
because of that
and he was not accepted even though he
was brilliant because he was the son of
the enemy of the people
and he
kind of broke him this experience that
he
didn't care when he was you know he went
to technical school and he didn't really
care that's my take on it
and then he ended up in this in this in
this little provincial town and he
thought he would escape from it as soon
as possible and then he met my mother
and I fell in love
and so I am sort of the product the
product of that you know of physics but
then
what I learned is that
because he was not able to overcome that
specific experience
it felt to me to do it and if I didn't
my son of my daughter would have I think
that that was one of the things I
learned
that was not by chance that our about
the same age
for slightly different reasons I was
subjected to the same kind of unfairness
and cruelty
and I in some ways I I feel like I did
it for him also I always because he was
also always so proud of me I was so
happy and I was I had this tremendous
gift
twice I was invited by American
mathematical Society
to give this big lectures twice it was
in 2012 and in 2018
and both times they were in Boston
it could be anywhere in the U.S both
times was in Boston
walking distance from my parents place
so he could be there with my mom as well
and that was such a gift that he was
beaming you know like seeing me on the
stage
so
you know
now that he's no longer here and it's
just you
know like I was still at my mom I still
have my sister yeah but as a man yeah
there's some aspect that it's
um
that it does hit you hard
um are you afraid of your own death do
you think about your death
are you afraid of it
I have a certain conceptual view of life
and death today which is informed by my
experiences in particular going through
my father's death
and that is something which cannot be
um conceptualized like that experience
like he could not
give it to somebody
one thing I will say
is that I felt that what it was it was
actually love totally exposed like naked
and you try to throw it is so acute so
being facing that love is incredibly
painful because it's so intense
one person is alive
we we have conversation we have wars we
have some actions we have some stuff is
going on and it puts a filter so you we
rarely actually feel love and it's
totally completely pure and adulterated
state but when person dies it's there
and it's staring at you and no matter
what you do you cannot turn away like I
try to it's like almost I felt like I
want to throw a blanket over it yeah it
burns like immediately like boom gone
it's there
live through it and I was I kept saying
to myself I just live through it live
through it that's how you and that's how
you know also learn what is love for
example what is it really
what is love what is life also because I
was completely
I had no idea and
and then you kind of learn that okay so
maybe it's not quite
there is more to it the more there is
more to eat there's more to this
experience than what can be put in a
concept or in a in a in a sentence in
this in a maybe poetry or music can do
some justice to it but if so then my own
life has that component has that
Dimension which is beyond anything I can
say about it you know and even though I
love this being this playing this role I
love it
and I kind of like it kind of makes me
feel different about all kinds of
difficulties that arise because it's
almost like I want to enjoy it because
that's what being human is it's being
it's being terrified it's being
frustrated it's being self-loathing
sometimes it's not knowing but also
being joyful and just like
ah let's just enjoy it kind of all of it
like that's why you came here for in
some sense you know it's like not trying
to run away from things but kind of
trying to just live through them and
appreciate so the biggest thing is
gratitude in some sense it's just
gratitude so thank you for letting me
play this is gratitude for every single
moment even if it's dark even if it's a
loss and that's why I am so people
around me they will say the total Doom
and Gloom and the world is ending and
I'm like
first of all that's how you see it okay
that's not the only point of view but
also even if it is like that's your
challenge like what are you going to do
about it stop complaining about other
people do something yourself how can you
make it a better world you know and I
think all of that starts with just a
gratitude for the moment to be able to
play this game yeah how beautiful it is
what uh we've talked about love but let
me ask what role does Love play in this
whole game in The Human Condition
it's like the glue you know it's like
for me it's like that
it's and it's not because people say
love is like um for a human being like a
romantic love yeah which is huge a
component of it obviously because so so
beautiful to be able to to express it in
this way but it could be love for what
you do for your passion for something
you know and uh
or
uh or love for for your for your friends
for instance or love it doesn't have to
be and so
in some sense that's that's what it's
all about in ultimately because
Living Without Love it's kind of
Bland boring and so
I don't think it's possible for science
to explain exactly what it is you can do
uh evolutionary biology perspective you
can talk about some kind of Sociology
perspective psychology perspective but
the experience
where you forget or time we're reminded
becomes an illusion and everything just
freezes oh my God
and then uh it's kind of beautiful and
painful to hear you say that when you've
experienced love the deepest is when you
lost it yes but in a sense you can say
that you could not have one without the
other I could not have that deep
connection with my father like really on
so so many levels
if they weren't a moment that's how I
see it and I'm not trying to say that's
how everybody should see for instance I
respect Rey Kurzweil I respect and I
feel and I almost like I I feel good
bumps right now I feel that desire to
reconnect
even if it is in the form of a you know
a computer program let's be honest about
it I find it to be very moving I find it
very moving and I understand because he
actually didn't have a chance to spend
much time you know I think he was 16 or
17 when he's he was a teenager he's dead
I was lucky because my father died I was
much older I've had so many moments with
him but that's not my thing like I think
it is the feature it's not a bug and it
sounds crazy like I would love I would
give anything to have him or here right
now right now I everything I have I give
it away right now yeah where do I sign
yeah just see him for one hour I promise
you I will
but I also know that I it then I'll
still lose him
or I will die or whatever you know so
that thing so what is why is it so worse
to just hold hold on to holding on to it
why why are we holding on to this and I
am the first sucker I'm the first man to
hold on but I'm questioning it now like
is there another way to approach life
where you just you know how Buddha it's
like
just let it go enjoy and let it go enjoy
and let it go is it possible
except the Paradox of it
well ask me in a couple of years you
know I will report but I think that it
but to my mathematical mind yeah it
sounds like a very interesting idea to
be honest because to me the idea of
holding isn't it sounds like an impasse
because no matter in all my experience
and if you look in history every time
somebody's holding you know it's how
they said in The Matrix whatever has a
beginning has an end it's like you
cannot go around it if you have a
beginning you could have an end so then
might as well just enjoy it and not
worry too much about extending it longer
that's how I see it now but maybe
tomorrow will be something else you know
yeah the roller coaster life the Paradox
of life right Edward you're an
incredible human being I've been a fan
for a long time thank you for writing
love and math thank you thank you for
being who you are being uh both one of
the greatest living mathematicians and
still
childlike Wander of the uh exploring the
how this whole world works the the
nature of the universe and thank you so
much for speaking with me today this is
amazing
been a pleasure thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Edward Frankel to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
Sophia kalalevska a Russian
mathematician
it is impossible to be a mathematician
without being a poet in the soul
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time